now
now is the part where we ask you if
we're live
if you can hear us i think we have
finally gone live
i think we finally got there streamlabs
is a great is a great
interface for many reasons however
lately
uh their their live button is not as uh
reliable can you hear my mic is on is
your mic on
my mic sounds nice can you hear us check
one this is the weirdest start to any of
our live streams
name that reference hello hello many
weird starts but this is definitely the
weirdest one
rizzo of course in the chat we got katie
orlando we got anissa we got
robert becerra and uh is the title gone
hey guys oh we're here all right i am
officially present that's how let's do
this
all righty how's it going guys how's
your friday going isn't comic-con
awesome
comic-con comic-con killing it this year
vidcon at home
is is just so crowded and annoying
and i'm gonna get covered yeah
so guys if this is your first time being
here tell us
say it in the comments say it in the
stream
and uh if this is not your first time
here say it in the stream
reynaldo torres torres out the gate with
an
a team losers crossover i love that 18
movie if you're talking about the movie
so i'm with you
party on dudes katie orlando here hello
all right john this is going to be a
focused live stream today this is going
to be one
where we are very much present i am
present and we are going to listen to
each
other we're going to listen we're going
to yes we're going to yes and each other
hey jenna randolph hi jenna we're going
to interact with the people here
right now we're competing for eyes we
never rarely do it this time on friday
but tomorrow
is justicecon where zack snyder supposed
to debut some snyder cut footage
and i wanted to make sure we were around
for that [ __ ] yeah all hands on deck for
the snyder cut
so guys all right we got a couple of
good ones in mind
i'm gonna kick this off all right so
today is gonna be the most
uh today's gonna be uh crossovers we'd
like to see
that being with characters last week we
did picture cinematic universe and then
today and then the
in during that stream someone was
pitching some characters and then i was
like
whoa that should have been the topic and
so today's topic
is going to be that and i feel like this
would be so much fun
this is gonna be so much fun i feel like
these are gonna be easy to just come off
the dome
too yeah yeah because you know you got
your generic ones
like that we've seen a billion times
like uh john wick versus jason bourne
john wick would win i'm just saying john
wick would win james bond versus jason
bourne jason
jason bourne will win james bond sucks
you going down bond jenna
i did notice you i said hello to you and
um
you know and then one that i've always
wanted to see is like
a fan fiction graphic novel of walter
white
versus um uh the dexter ozark
yeah versus jason bateman or something
i've never
and then you know another cliche one
that we hear all the time
is uh when the hell is ash williams
going to be versing
freddie and jason that's another one
that we want to see constantly you know
especially freddie and also uh in terms
of crossover
one are dwayne and jazz gonna go
toe-to-toe with greg and john from the
real rejects when are we gonna fight
each other
dude if she'll take [ __ ] jazz will take
all of us down
yeah but hey if logan paul can get a
successful fighting career off the
ground or jake paul or one of the paul's
then we can do it
yeah that's true we turning on that
that's a standard that we can hold
ourselves to is is the pauls
we got jack sparrow shouting out an
alien and terminator crossover get
wayland
and skynet ooh hello soul nice to see
you here
jaws versus bigger jaws from dalton
gerwig that's a name i haven't seen yet
come on john pitch a couple who were a
couple you'd like to see
okay this is one that i really actually
do want to see
it's not gonna happen but i don't care
because i think that the worlds and i
know you've already heard me say this
but i think the worlds
of pacific rim and terminator need to
cross
over to get an extra player in the game
so the humans we've already figured out
how to take on the kaiju as of the last
movie
and then what should arise right as
we're about to take the fight to them
skynet and what do they make a giant
terminator
powered by two drift compatible
terminators that's what i'm talking
about john
so then it's the humans in their giant
machine versus the terminators but then
the terminators figure out how the
machine works so the humans need to
build
a bio-organic giant you got a whole
movie in order to fight the terminator
yeah
i also would like to see captain kirk
oh versus no
okay here's what i'd love to see
i'd love to see william shatner's
captain kirk today
shatner today yes reversing chris pines
kirk
it would be a really boring fight it
would i don't know what the excitement
of that fight would be
patrick stewart judging the fight we're
doing verses but i just like to see them
team up
yeah hey number one i don't know why
we've done that yeah
the the topic is team up as well and
honestly this might be sacrilege but i
feel like if you did it an
actual team up between like uh uh if you
just did something that involved
starfleet
in the star wars world yeah i think that
could work like it would only serve to
expand
i think what we need before he passes on
is uh sylvester stallone's rocky versus
rambo
oh yes that would be an epic fight would
it not be
it'll be would it not be an epic it
would be like the expendables meets dr
doolittle or one of those movies where
like
eddie murphy plays everybody except
stallone i love it
okay um let's go through the comments
here really fast the avengers and
kingsman secret service crossover i
don't know what the kingsmen would
really
give to the avengers i feel like yeah
they that they don't already have in
black women that's what jenna's saying
in the chat
you know i'm not sure what that would do
i saw oh who was i saying indiana
jones jones indiana jones versus hans
landa
oh man this would be like a weird like
one-on-one psychological
cinema critic reviews in the chat is
saying uh robocop versus the terminator
you can experience that immortal combat
11
right now that's right i think the
terminator would win
i think so if you just have a toe-to-toe
fight with the terminator versus robocop
terminator would win
i i get that sense because the
terminator also like i love this topic
this should be the topic every weekend i
don't know why we haven't
always crossed this should be the topic
every weekend yeah
paul povenmeier said kramer versus
predator
yes and the sequel predator versus
creepy oh batman vs predator batman vs
predator would be [ __ ] awesome
yeah i would root for batman but that
would be a real challenge you know dude
batman would have a hard time winning
but he could win remake
predator but with batman level supes so
they're not people like superman who
could easily kill them but but yeah make
them with like
those characters and see what happens um
let's see here
thanos and darkseid team uh from rm dust
i think i think we need to see the
snyder cut to really see
is that the dark which dark side are we
talking we're talking about comics
crossover we're talking about the dark
side that we
think will be in the snyder cut because
then that would be exciting
uh sarah and chad judge dredd versus the
mandalorian
campbell what's up mask off yeah you
could have uh
dre oh a mask off and that would be so
fun mask on mask it sounds like you
could get a really boring movie out of
it but i actually
no no it would be boring if they were
both like faceless slasher villains yeah
um like if it was like if it was like
jason voorhees versus michael myers
like he's supposed to just be really
quiet a 10-minute short film of that
sounds cool
walking at each other but a feature film
of that sounds boring
but with the mandalorian like they're
amanda with mando
versing judge dredd
they did i mean yeah you go for the
sylvester stallone
everyone's favorite what are you talking
about
that's so
this mouth position allows i want to see
uh martin scorsese versus the marvel
cinematic universe
let's bring that fight back around yes
oh and have him in like a chair with
like a massive
brain thing yeah perfect joker versus
pennywise
i feel like would be no competition
right now we're doing mel gibson versus
covid
that's a real life crossover yeah yeah i
wonder we should have an osmosis
jones that takes place during this time
in mel gibson's body
thank you guys for the oh yeah you got
some new people hello hello to everyone
who's here for their first time this is
gonna be a fun one
all right well it's been fun already i
love this topic it's just so
i i just keep it going guys the verses
or the team ups whichever ones you want
here's one that i think will work on
both levels sure it's
okay so you take every
jaman hansu character and then have them
team up
and form their own avengers there you go
or have them all fight each other but i
feel like it would be cooler if you see
every single one of them get to be a
different member of the the hansu squad
i love spider dark's uh requests grace
randolph versus jessica chastain
jeff i would i would
because grace put together a wonderful
interview with zack snyder recently
i think it would be great if she
officially interviewed jessica chastain
i would i would love it i would love
that i would i think
her first question should be so
why do you suck why are you a pain in
the ass he's so funny
do you think uh a really nice message um
but yeah guys we got a few uh what are
we gonna say john i think grace should
do like a spice girls cosplay because
every time i hear that so
my brain immediately goes to tell you
what i want ooh bane versus
thanos i mean bain would get his ass
owned thanos but it would be cool to
watch for like
five seconds to watch that fight each
other
thank you to everyone who's super
chatted we have uh super chats here on
youtube but we also have the stream lab
ones as well
uh let's go through some of these to see
what you guys got we got
okay we how do we make how do we make we
always have some terrible gimmick
every week for how to make them feel
special for those who super chat
or contribute in the stream labs which
one
what should we do today because we're
running out of freestyles yeah they're
only selling words
i don't know eminem's done it for 50
years
well you know he's got the thesaurus on
his nightstand every night
uh let's see we could um agoraphobic
fanboy we could do like a word
association game
i say fanboy and the first word that
comes to your mind
so we're rhyming again no it could be
anything a word association for them
all right this is just the first idea
that came to mind but you know we could
do something different
all right let's try it out john let me
see what you're going for the
agoraphobic fanboy
convention hall this isn't very good
this is a weird
boy and i thought the sccc conventional
and yeah
well you know you gotta you gotta at
least throw something out there right
you gotta you gotta fail to move up
peter pacheco was saying no freestyle i
was really hoping by saying that uh we
shouldn't just keep doing the freestyles
that more
people will be like like please two more
freestyles
i was really hoping that's what it would
be hello to everyone who's tuning in
here
okay bristol game we're gonna go with
ryan batey's once as he holds down our
discord so well
a positive compliment for each one oh
you mean like the most basic thing you
can do
the agoraphobic most traditional thing
you could do for when someone shows up
i think the agoraphobic fanboy is
perfect the way he is because he doesn't
even need to go outside he lights up a
room
yes and there you go i think agoraphobic
fanboy he's been contributing to
our uh super chats weekly uh for the
past few weeks already so thank you so
much dude there's nothing wrong being
agoraphobic as long as you own it
yeah don't worry give it some time tm we
might run into more freestyles knowing
us
oh yeah so what's it what is his
suggestion today suggestion is
daniel larusso meets rocky balboa
preferably cobra kai creed era
also also i'm getting married next week
would you mean the world if you could
wish uh give us a good luck
shout out thanks guys oh that's amazing
congratulations congratulations on your
upcoming wedding
break a leg weird to get married during
covet times i've heard of other people
doing it and they kind of
turned into strange weddings however it
doesn't matter about that what matters
is
you're getting married just don't cheat
on her and don't kiss the bride
just you know rub your masks together if
you have time
danger make sure she's not cheating on
you yes
because if she is how is she doing it
it's coveted times it's
really hard right now so it's impressive
if she is yeah i guess even more reason
to marry her i say
if you're running around successfully
right now i i guess you must be good at
it
daniel larusso meaning rocky balboa i
know exactly what would go down in that
fight let's hear it
when i think of rocky fighting i think
of rocky one and two
because then rocky iii is when he gets
like a real apollo cree trains him so he
learns to fight like a real fighter but
on one and two he's like
yeah it's not very fluid so um
i think they would be fighting in the
ring and then what would daniel larusso
do what would he do
he would do the the crane thing exactly
which you can't do in a boxing fight or
his sweeping leg
that would be an interesting mashup um
yeah because you think of it like maybe
rocky balboa moves yes into the valley
that wants to open his own boxing gym
and gets into some kind of weird
conflict with daniel arus
or what about adonis creed versus daniel
russo
i mean he'd kill him he murdered he
would
i think anytime you got this big of an
age gap they're [ __ ] one of them's
[ __ ]
whoever's would probably destroy him
just because i don't know like he's
he's just so much bigger like he's
beefier he looks like he
he i don't know i mean maybe daniel
russo could edge him out with the
agility because he's like light and
crappy
right right you know it'd be a good
fight it'd be a good fight well thanks
fight night all right compliment number
two time coming your way
for anissa oliva oh yes what can i say
about anissa man
uh look i we we compliment you every
single week
so this week we're going to insult you
we're going to insult the [ __ ] out of
you
jesus and what gives what gives why are
you so awesome why are you so
generous why are you so beautiful stop
why do you
why do you help build the reject
community so much especially
on our discord where i found out all you
guys at discord are actually conversing
with each other
yeah oh yeah that's bizarre there's so
many boards now that's crazy that's so
awesome yeah
anissa you have helped us grow literally
as people as a channel you've helped us
grow so much
thank you so much thank you my dear
john's penis grows when he sees you
amazing yep john wick at the term
and the matrix sorry john wick in the
matrix crossover let's make it happen it
would just make
sense also hi guys how are you how's
your day going
you know i think it would actually be
really cool if john wick did fight me
i mean neo would win yeah i mean all neo
has
you know there's this fight in the
matrix reloaded it was when the
merovingian sends all his people at him
the chateau fight i think is what it's
called
and uh it's it's like the best fight
in the matrix reloaded when he's when he
was using all the weapons
yeah yet i think it's the best fight
it's so
well beautifully choreographed every
time i watch it i'm like
why is neo fighting why is he doing this
he doesn't you know he doesn't need to
do all this does he
you know and that would be the problem
if neil because like the idea of neo and
john wick or john wick existing in the
same universe sounds so cool oh
yes there should be a keanu crossover
verse ted theodore logan neo
and john wick all together guy and the
devil's advocate guy
they should all cross over into the
keanu verse
yes oh dude keanu verse that even has a
nice ring to it
it really does it really does because
there's a u at the end of keanu so it
naturally
works ah perf that's a great
thanks anisa perforated yes carter uh
carter lovejoy thank you for your
contribution dude carter lovejoy's name
fills me with love and joy whenever i
see it i would love to see
well okay compliment compliment for
carter launched into a freestyle
carter is usually one of the first
people who like
we don't never expect this and when it
happens it's always a really pleasant
surprise and very generous
when people like super chat before we're
even live because we don't even get to
the super chat so like a few minutes in
at least
and carter generally super chats before
we're even live
and that that always stands out to us so
thank you for doing that dude and you
i've seen your name in our comment boxes
for years
so a lot of people will be like i've
been watching you for so many years
uh x amount yet carter is one of those
people i'm like oh i know this guy
so thank you for being who you are
carter and yet i've never seen your face
not even in a profile pic so thank you
dude you could be anyone
um dude don't care i'm i'm also skimming
what's going on in the live stream chat
and we got to go through some of these
pics
like there's gonna be some good pictures
yeah popping off with good ideas this is
my favorite topic we've ever done
you heard it here first erica tuesday i
know you're in the chat start making
some fanfic comics
all right oh dude you could probably you
could yeah
make a little like comic series out of
those bring our ideas to life
i would love to see a crossover of
carter lovejoy is saying i would love to
see a crossover literally every big
studio franchise
i'm talking marvel i'm talking dc
i'm talking star wars star trek
disney which encompasses about three of
those
pixar harry potter 007
lord of the rings fnf jurassic park
transformers what would that movie you
know what it would be you know the
avengers end game when they're all
showing up at the end that's what that
movie would be for two and a half hours
yeah everyone's showing up it would be a
two-hour super hero bowl or a super
villain bowl or something like that
where it's just you're zipping around
and people are showing up and dying and
showing up and dying and
part one would be them show it up for
two and a half hours you got dominic
toretto appearing you got the indominus
rex appearing to all fight the big
baddies of
all the because because it wouldn't just
be the protagonists of those franchises
which you got to do is get the
antagonists of those franchises too
the t-rex comes in riding the indominus
rex oh my god
blue is riding the t-rex pratt is riding
that's what i'm talking about stack them
up and then it smashes to black
yes part two would just be them fighting
ooh i think we need to call jeff
hollywood
i think if we ever got word that the
that the end of the world if god just
came from the sky
and was like world's ending in one year
what are you gonna do
i think all the studios should come
together to make this movie that's what
you that's that's
might be my dream right there all the
studio yeah a movie about all the
studios setting their differences aside
and coming together to enjoy the rapture
hey mr vahu in the chat you're saying
greg alba versus watson i know you're
referring to my cat from hell episode
just gotta say it's greg alba and watson
now oh
team jackson galaxy saved everything
and then jackson galaxy is the nick fury
of this universe
let's do uh let's do two more here
because these are the first ones that
came in and then we'll and then we'll
take and then we'll look around oh and
we also we also got some people on our
stream lab so i do want to get to that
yes siree uh we got rizzo gaming back in
action although we haven't uh
uh commented complimented rizzo yet
today so
ryan beatty and b my god you give us the
best facts about
oh my god doctor who who should dr who
cross over with
i think if doctor who like boarded the
enterprise one day that would be a great
doctor who on the star trek enterprise i
would adore that
[ __ ] beautiful that'd be great that'd
be a great team though what about doctor
who on like the millennium falcon
what was that not as exciting that
wouldn't be as exciting no i think star
trek and doctor who are more akin than
doctor
who and star wars so i think that would
work a lot better definitely
it actually i think they would complete
each other nicely because i think star
trek leans toward the brain and doctor
who leans toward the heart so together i
think that would be something really
nice yeah and ryan beatty is constantly
informative
and like keeping us up to date on some
fun facts with doctor who and on top of
that he suggested this idea that we
compliment our people here
and he suggested we'd be nice
giving it a try how about this how about
this be nice today
don't don't
um yeah i mean ryan elsa really has
helped out with the discord a lot is
always encouraging people to hit the
like button on the stream so right thank
you so much for
you know you you you're the you're like
our manager
you are yeah you're our trusty moderator
oh my goodness why did this not pop into
my mind so well ryan the crossover he
wants to see
is ryan reynolds deadpool and wolverine
human ryan i would just like to see how
ryan reynolds and hugh jackman movie at
this point
i want to see like them as logan and
wade but just
hanging out you know hanging out you
know it would be cool besides
wolverine and deadpool hanging out i
think it would be cool to see a movie
kind of like a this is the end style
okay but with hugh jackman and ryan
reynolds like they're playing satire
versions of themselves
uh yes and it could be about them trying
to make a crossover
of wolverine and deadpool that would be
the most meta thing and then the
post-credits scene would reveal
this was a deadpool movie the entire
time every time and then deadpool kills
them both and that's the only moment he
shows up
is that honestly that's not a bad idea
where's cosmic wonder tell him this is a
reddit leak and he will
do a video on it yes oh
sorry straight one in the chat but the
thing versus the blob sounds
and then let's see brittany lang
brittany lang changing the profile
photo and always surprising us with a
medley of wonderful and enchanting
profile
pics not to mention generosity insight
and it's always 27.99 canadian
it's it's always that same amount and i
appreciate that and you uh
what i respect out of uh like there's a
lot of qualities i respect out of people
but one of the qualities i respect most
consistency
and thank you for being such a wonderful
mom to me
she's my mom brittany lang's my mom oh
well done hey guys happy friday how's it
going
what is one movie you guys most looking
forward to seeing next year
uh i don't know i'm going to assume
shane chee
is coming out next year the batman is
the one i'm most anticipating
yeah um i would say batman's the one i'm
most looking forward to out of them all
i'm still super jacked for spiral yeah
that was my big like bummer move back uh
i mean i
i would have said bill and ted 3 had
they not kept it on the vod track
yeah that's true but yeah that's a good
call batman or uh yeah
spiral i feel like watching batman
crossover with anyone
would just be exciting in another that
should be like there should just be a
batman
and universe well with this topic of
crossovers is like that idea of the bat
verse
with opening it up because like
when they did when they announced
spider-man into the spider-verse i think
there were some
there were i won't say it was the
majority but i think there was a small
amount i was kind of worried about the
fact of how like there was
they kept rebooting spider-man they
opened up this spider-verse category it
could seem like it's a little too much
from sony or whatever
and with batman that's kind of the
conversation that's happening right now
like there's so much
batman all the time and i think we're at
the point now that if they did
some movie where they crossed over like
ben affleck's batman michael keaton's
robert pattinson's getting christian
bale to show up
somehow i don't know how that then i
think
uh i think that would actually be
appropriate it would really work
yeah man i agree agree i'm not sure
anywho uh yeah so let's who's in the
stream labs right now
let's find date let's go all the way
down
let's go the way done we got katie and
first up today
all right yeah we got katie anne katie
anne is my daughter wonderfully poetic
very much so as a person who cares a
hell of a lot about individuals children
especially
very empowering very encouraging i love
chatting with this woman
through the lookingglass.water.blog
check out her
check out her reviews they're wonderful
so what is her question today
john what is the worst movie theater
experience you've ever had
i.e audience sound cutting out or sold
out ps
thank you for all that you do shout out
to our reject family too
we appreciate all the laughs and love
that you work so tirelessly to share
okay so for any question if it's a
random question that we get that's not
related to crossovers
we're gonna find a way to whatever story
we're telling
about turning it back into the topic
okay
with this bad audience crosses over with
that audience or maybe they verse each
other
um do you have a specific one
a specific uh do you have one i mean
i've got a couple that come to mind
what are they um when i went to see uh
texas chainsaw 3d
that was one of the most aggravating
screenings
i i have been to partly because the
audience was already rowdy and
and like goofing around and having you
know and it was
kind of fine at first however the my
friend right next to me was
so drunk was so drunk and he was just
shouting stuff out and rambling and and
like
rocking around and just like yeah he was
just it was like the theater was
obnoxious and my friend was being
obnoxious and so i was like i don't know
really what to do here because like
you're kind of in fitting with the room
but you're also bigger than the room and
i'm not vibing with the room at all and
this movie is kind of dumb
uh so that one was just a vividly uh uh
you know icky experience kind of but uh
halloween two rob zombies halloween two
was
such a bad screening that i didn't
really remember the movie afterwards
like i had to sit in the very front left
like because it was only
the only theater in town that had it was
universal citywalk in like their after
thought tiny theater
and so yeah i was sitting there and like
people were shouting
and like throw it was like that theater
in uh scream
like i've never seen a theater look like
in scream when like everyone's just like
going nuts
throwing popcorn but that was that was
my halloween two screening
okay i i got i got a crossover idea then
okay michael myers from the original
franchise
versing michael myers from the soft
reboot versing rob
zombies michael myers the only one who's
actually
be able to distinguish because he he
emotes
yeah yeah this is in the second one he
starts doing it yeah he
starts taking off his mask and growing
beer yes so then you get
a michael myers into the meyer versus
crossover
uh idea i think the one that annoys me
the most um would be
uh in terms to answer your question
katie anne
would be any time andrew gordon talk too
much during a movie to predict
everything that's going to happen
or when john's breathing too loud yeah
it was one of the it's real hard for me
to think of a specific
one like black panther john's breathing
really loud and then ever like john
just relish having clear nostrils you
know and then andrew on my other side of
me during black panther
it's vibranium he wasn't actually
predicting things
oh no but every like 10 minutes you go
yeah it's like everybody's just like you
do this like huge size
i got a consistent sigh of john on my on
my right
and then a consistent breathing
challenge stereo and then
and then andrew just like take a deep
breath out every time you're stuck in an
asmr nightmare
but but black panther versus
andrew gordon black who would be a cool
one for black panther diverse
let's see i don't want to just say
another black guy red skull
just haven't beat the [ __ ] i should have
just let you say that before i said
i don't want to say just another but oh
because i feel like that's what we
usually do with like the black
characters like
what other k what other black character
can they burst let them kill the the the
skeleton nazi man
that being said i think it would be cool
to watch chadwick bozeman's
black panther versus mahershalali's what
oh no actually it'd be really cool for
him to first wesley snipes blade
yes yeah that'd be awesome see that's
the thing is i feel like snipes
snipes would take maybe that one uh oh
i have i i think michael from the rob
zombie movies would win
uh just because he's yeah but uh i have
one
one more theater experience came to mind
it was when i saw king kong
peter jackson's king kong in the
cinerama dome
which is more money than
a regular ticket and this guy was behind
us a few roses me and my dad we were
seeing it like opening weekend we were
excited
and this guy in like a fedora he was
like goatee like he looked very
put together like he was out on a friday
night and he was just sitting there with
his leg up
making fart sounds every time kong would
move just like whenever kong started
walking he was just
like and and nobody
did anything that's a memory and we lost
seven viewers now because of your fart
story
i know i'm sorry i didn't mean to bring
bodily functions into this we have to
stick to the topic at hand
well you know uh you know indigestion
crosses over with king kong and then you
know he's not able to make it to the
godzilla fight
but hookah king converse ooh um
let's have him versus donald trump
i mean it would be a gratifying match uh
versus who's the the ape in uh rampage
that would make sense
oh my god you should get an ape
crossover king kong versus old king kong
versus 1970s king kong
versus congo versus mighty joe young
versus caesar from planet of the apes
that would be
versus uh jane goodall and gorillas in
the mist oh who will be the dominant it
would be
it would be the most recent king kong
because he's the biggest one oh yeah if
he's as big as guys
the fight's over he's already versing
godzilla so you know but all the way
that
photo of godzilla versus gong looks
pretty sick does look p
sweet meme mimi m
mimi is constantly expanding our
horizons
with musical tastes and also political
insights on culture that i
adore reading whatever you send to us so
thank you mimi for being who you are
keeping us both informed and enlightened
with
sounds and images so she's saying storm
and t'challa
team up and atlanta and insecure
crossover shows
i want i i want i i haven't seen atlanta
or
or or insecure you see i want issa to
meet uh
darius or even van oh my god i ca okay
so darius is the character that uh
uh uh uh lakey stanfield plays and then
van is uh
zassie bates okay so uh yeah and then
issa reyes is right
but i i would love to see either of
those worlds collide especially if
if insecure wound up in atlanta somehow
because i want to see that fantasy take
you know hold there oh hey happy
birthday julian garcia see you in the
chat right now
and storm and t'challa teaming up i i'm
pretty confident we're gonna see
aurora monroe in the next black panther
movie i'm more than confident we're
gonna see that
do you want janelle monae to play her
let me just
text ryan coogler real fast
get coogs on the horn he's a fan and he
wanted to talk to me so yeah
he's been begging to join these live
streams
and then let's just do a couple more
here and i want to go back to the chat
room ryan
chandler named after your favorite
friend ryan chandler oh my god
what can i say about ryan chandler
he's the best his name is named after my
favorite friends character
and also one of my favorite youtubers
ryan george
hey and one of my favorite actors ryan
gosling he's an amazing human being this
ryan chandler
and that's how he got his name he sends
those things
one time i was drunk driving and
uh he switched spots with me from the
passenger seat when the cops pulled us
over
he got in he took the hit man went to
jail for
30 days ryan chandler so glad to see you
in our stream labs right now
you're awesome hey guys how about marty
mcfly
goes too far into the future and ends up
with arnold's terminator chasing him
through time it could be back to the
future too
but with the terminator killing everyone
strickland
biff needles marty's family all debt
this is a
very bleak back to the future crossover
that you want to do
or the terminator is just stomping
everyone the entire time
i would love it i was i was there when
you said marty mcfly encountering the
terminator because he went too far into
the future then i was like oh my god
this is so dark
yeah he's gonna wipe out the entire
timeline it sounds like
just all the images oh imagine that
montage though just all of the pictures
hung in marty's house
draining of their images you know all
the people in them
as arnold rubs them all out guys keep it
going in the live stream chat i'm loving
everything we're seeing we're gonna
we're gonna hop back in there in just a
second man
eric was here eric horstmann one day we
will go to atlanta you have my word when
i feel safe to go i i've seriously been
planning it in my head i've had talks
with olivia but i really want to go to
atlanta to meet eric
i gotta see this real rejects tattoo you
got in person
uh you're always so honest with us i
love you man
i really love you eric thank you for
being you so much you're you're an
incredibly sweet human being love you
buddy and he's just saying just hey for
now
hey buddy thanks eric hi appreciate
that major contribution too by the way
uh you're so sweet thank you oh we got
queen anisa
queen and easter queen and is that you
this is so liberal
or is it a new anissa who's trying to
steal your name i think it's the same
anissa i think it's the same anissa
anissa sexton's got a great ass elsa
everyone
we are having i've never seen it but i'm
just i'm just gonna say it
everyone go check out her modeling page
also everyone we having a little discord
live chat while watching the live stream
so
come and hang out come and join our
little community
so apparently at our discord there are
people who are like video chatting with
each other after the live stream so
there's like
a lot of the reject nations becoming a
real they assume we will have our own
state
so appreciate that for shouting that out
means a lot yeah
and we got flev doran last but not least
right now in the stream labs
oh no yeah yeah right now that's cool
flev has been consistent with being here
yeah every week
thank you so much such a distinct name
is it short for something is it short
for like flavium
i don't know what is oh goodness i have
jumped
what have you done john wow you click
too many buttons you get way too antsy i
ruined it all you get way too antsy you
get so nervous
and then you just [ __ ] it all up for
everyone i know especially when you're
uh john come on come on john you're
screwing up the stream
i know you're screwing up the stream
you're embarrassing i know we're about
to get
cancelled for the
this is a behind the scenes experience
of me just yelling at john what are you
doing oh my gosh
ruin everything i fixed it i fixed it i
found flip oh there we go
hi guys mine is a bit of a deep cut
uh make sure that this is in frame all
right there we go hi guys mine's a bit
of a deep cut i would like to see
someday a hunter hunter you yu
hakusho crossover both are created by
togashi
uh yyh is one of my favorite shows
ever and i just started hunter hunter so
that would be
cool that would be cool man that would
be cool i really
i really want more animes to cross over
with each other uh my girlfriend's been
showing me
uh samurai shamplo which is so [ __ ]
cool and it would be cool if cowboy
bebop and samurai shampoo ever had a
crossover with each other once so
far in the future and space travel and
such
and the other one's a samurai show
like i don't know how that would work
but maybe they go
through some wormhole that time travels
um
time travels and back in time to the
samurai world i mean i think that would
be pretty sweet
i like the idea i like it all right
thanks vlad for that thank you so much
my dear flev
all right guys let's get that title back
let's do
uh a speed round of all the crazy ones
you guys have been putting
in the regular chat when this graphic is
on screen that means we're just looking
at the chat ooh
vince rivera good place in pushing
daisy's crossover that's a cool one for
tv
i think that would be neat so samurai
jack meets mortal kombat
i actually think samurai jack putting
him in as a dlc character in mortal
kombat will be a blast
yes um let's see here
ryan wright and jerry versus greg alba
and john
humphrey um i think ryan wright would
easily win
and jerry would would morph bodies with
john is what would happen
yes into one like in uh
like in jojo's bizarre adventure if
you've seen that oh raccadillo ash
versus evil dead with the walking dead
i would certainly give that show that
i've heard is much better now
a shot in the arm for the place i'd
definitely give it a different flavor
it would actually you know i think
there's a version where you can make
that work there's got to be at least a
fan fake comic where you could bring
that to life
i think once you got negan in the game
you can get ash in there
i think you should just throw ash in
there in the next season
he wakes up in the apocalypse he wakes
up in the zombie apocalypse
yeah like what the hell is going on
that'd be so funny yeah just just say
that you picked up from the army of
darkness original ending and go from
there
uh let's see what else do we got here
let's see let's see russell brand versus
jim carrey
i i don't know who would win but i think
russell brand would probably be more
amusing
all right let's see here chris is just
saying agents of shield and the mcu who
the greatest crossover that they didn't
get
yes i agree with you well speaking of
crossovers you got to get daredevil and
spider-man to crossover in a movie
that's like the dream duo for me right
there
it's about time also yes we do have to
get a photo with eric
with uh eric's tattoo with us on the
either side doing thumbs up that's
that's the only reason we're gonna go to
atlanta at all
ooh for us sylvester friends and the big
bang theory
crossover i don't know if they share the
same kind of audiences where that would
really work so that might actually make
it more appealing okay
okay have they done an american dad and
family guy crossover yet like
an official one where there's like two
episodes dedicated to american dad and
family guy
i don't know why they haven't done it
because that would be awesome that would
work totally well yeah
that ought to have happened and like
like tyler slavin saying in the chat
uh the office and parks and rec reunion
crossover that's one i've always wanted
to see too
i'm surprised i'm still surprised that
that didn't happen in a bigger way okay
let's do some characters here really
fast
i would love to see
how about you name a character and i'll
name another one okay i
picked name any character rocket raccoon
rocket record
what do you say like that you know
rocking you off guard that way
so that people take note i would love to
see rocket raccoon
versing dobby from the harry potter for
hedgehogs
hey that could actually be a
surprisingly decent fight because dobby
knows how to apparate
dobby has certain magic like and then
rocket has sci-fi
tech um i'm i'm on the last episode of
the first season of doom patrol right
now
i think doom patrol and umbrella academy
would be the most ultimate crossover
television can give us right now
i can see that um that'd be great
oh who would j how about this john okay
because i'm seeing uh
a puff puffin mirror in the chest of
batman vs jigsaws what about
jigsaw versus who jigsaw
versus moriarty
sherlock holmes yeah actually
that would be cool homes and jigs would
be pretty sweet
i would be down for that yeah if you get
one master
intellect versus another really cool and
then sherlock holmes wakes up in the
trap and it's not a regular trap it's an
intellectual trap
oh rory saying hannibal lecter versus
the riddler
oh if the riddler is setting up clues
for him like i'm talking mads
mickelson's hannibal lecter
that would be actually a very thrilling
mystery to watch hell yeah
and i feel like i feel like hannibal
would befriend edward nigma in the end
i could yeah i could imagine that i see
lloyd says uh zack snyder versus kevin
feige
i think that is a celebrity death match
actually lloyd's saying the flash
quicksilver and a train crossover
what would they all do together they'd
race each other just have another race
they'd race who's doing more i believe
flash and quicksilver did race in some
comic edition but i'm not
don't don't 100 percent quote yeah
wasn't there something like that
i also see here uh uh where was that one
uh i lost it zombieland in the walking
dead and the last of us that's one
um damn thanos versus the seven i think
thanos would definitely
win that situation you're looking at me
i just love watching you
like when you get quiet when you're like
i'm like
you're going to just reading mode no
yeah cause like there was one that i
have my eyeball on
like right underneath zack snyder versus
kevin feige i think uh
oh yeah there you go niraj that's why i
was looking for niraj because he says he
wants to see lil nikki
and hellboy
i mean morbidly i want to see that for
at least five minutes
like if they did like one of those old
school mtv sketches or something for
like the movie awards
like i would watch that okay i got i got
a new one for you guys just popped in my
head
stitch and yoda
that would be a very throaty oh my god
you gotta do the creepy little guy
crossovers
yoda stitch gollum
oh dabi um i guess rocket raccoon he
doesn't quite fit in that category
a little creepy leprechaun leprechaun
uh i mean do they all have to be creepy
could we get like uh like willow or the
guy from fantasy island
i guess yeah that works
i guess that works just as well um and
katie orlando in the chat trying to
figure out what [ __ ] is so that's a
great transition too oh yeah go
go up on urban dictionary and you'll
find let's get back to
the super chats right now guys google it
all right
you guys are picking some great picks
let me shout out the most recent one
here
um resident evil and silent hill
crossing over into that world
have they done that yet have they not
made that game i don't think they have i
think the sensibilities clash
a bit but i would love to see i think
some of the earlier resident evil games
could definitely get uh
into some silent hill you know territory
i think i i would have to be able to
rectify the supernatural quality
or or how about this johnny depp versus
amber heard
and just looks like an ass
and it all takes place in their bed
yeah just versus a giant and the
solution is
johnny depp has to pee on it and write
his name i
know they're crazy crazy couple those
too all right
i love i love the headlines that have
started coming out of that that
what's weird about the giant dip amber
heard trial is that there's this channel
called
incredibly average which has been
putting out almost
ever most of what's been coming out of
the trial that's being publicized
most of it he's already reported on has
showed so much of that leaked audio and
stuff i'm like yeah i know this yeah i
know this
yeah i know this so and it's just funny
how now
more people are latching on to it ooh
ooh
jeans in the chat lawn order svu versus
versus ps5
xbox versus playstation let's get it
going why svu
specifically no way okay you gotta
understand i did not steal yours peter
pacheco
uh when i said it because i'm i'm
looking i
my eyes are a little bit blurry right
now and and where the super chats are
being read
are a little too far of a distance where
i'm that's why i'm usually like leaning
in to try to see them
but peter pacheco who has one of the
best
profile pics in the world captain saul
spalding
sid haig may you rest in peace he says
umbrella academy versus doom patrol
versus deadly class
we gotta start a deadly class at some
point okay that's the anime
show right yeah yeah i know little about
it but i know that
see i watched umbrella academy first
which is you know
primarily takes place at a mansion where
all these people live together with
super powers and they're very
dysfunctional group of folks but they're
a family they're all brothers and
sisters
and the person who was uh the person who
led them they called father was like a
crazy professor x of sorts right and
then i started doom patrol and it's kind
of a similar setup but then
once you get going with it you're like
oh it's actually a very different show
yeah timothy dalton's in it beyond that
it's
very like dude doom patrol i just said
this on stardust today
is the best live-action dc thing i've
seen
um like outside of the dark knight it is
my fa uh
hands down my face i haven't seen season
two yet but i would say doom patrol
is uh has anyone seen season two yet
yeah there's eight episodes it's out
yeah there's eight episodes out oh wow
one day
you should have been a [ __ ] smart ass
and here i do slapping you in the face
with my knowledge
all right [ __ ] that's the last time i
attempt to foil you in a livestream
peter pacheco thank you thank you bud
and thank you
also compliment for being patient with
me still not knowing
the portuguese accent all right so who
do we got dragon
soldier dragon soldier just has a ba
badass nickname or screen name and uh
you
inspire me to be tough one time
dragon soldier um i i had to do a drug
test
and he swapped urine with me oh that's
really really kind he's a
very kind human was it good urine did
you test it before you
these are real compliments these are
great compliments jay
and silent bob cross over with bill and
ted maybe
oh i think that would be a heck of a lot
of fun and
jay and silent bob's world would totally
open itself to that
the thing though was you would have to
make bill and ted r-rated at that point
this is also true where other than a
couple of jokes they're
it's like vulgar or innuendos or
whatever that's
that's the one thing about bill ted's
three that i'm not picking up at
all at all and i wish i brought it up in
the trailers is that there's
there seems to be like no sexual jokes
at all with that movie whereas the first
two definitely have that
yeah and there's none of that in this
other one mm-hmm
and it feels like a family film and so
with that would bill and tech cross over
jansson actually you know what
it could work uh kevin smith i think is
actually hosting
the panel this saturday for bill and ted
oh and he's already seen it and he said
and like he
before he agreed to host it he said he
saw it and he's like was so in love with
bill and ted face the music like just
made him so happy watching it
and uh yeah yeah i could see a version
of that war works either that or wayne's
world
peter pacheco's back beatrix kiddo
killville vs katana from
suicide squad i mean
visually that would be a very cool ass
fight
i'm a little afraid that katana's katana
would probably make the ultimate
difference
nah man beatrix has overcome anything
that's true actually like
she had climbed out of a grave she
climbed out of a grave she was in a coma
for four years woke up and was like i
want revenge right away
she survived a bullet in the head man
that yeah
and not all of us were lucky seeing that
stallone movie
she took on the crazy 88.
dude she did all while that cool song
was playing so i'm saying that like i
actually think
beatrix kiddo would dominate over
katana from david ayer's suicide squad
now whatever crazy comic edition you got
from katana i'm talking david a or
suicide squad
i think uh beatrix kiddo from kill bill
would own her true that i agree i'm i'm
with you i'm with you there i'm with you
g
sylvester fry son junior sylvester
is constantly giving some of the best
like
he when we we when we don't have the
super chats or stream labs
on screen and we're going through just
the live stream uh
uh chat sylvester generally has
some of the ones that i love to
highlight like he often has like the
most creative suggestions so thank you
steven
sylvester steven who's stephen are you
stephen
the incredible team up with big hero oh
dude that's the one thing the
incredibles are missing is a medic
they could have their own medic they
could have baymax like like like 10
to kids or like people who were injured
and then the rest of the team would fit
perfectly with them like that would be
great
i think that would be very cool
incredibles end game let's do this the
incredibles and big hero 6 working
together and their animation styles are
not so far off that you couldn't blend
them together in the same world hey man
they're down the hall all you got to do
is jump the pixar fence into disney
world that would really work
yeah yeah call brad bird like i said man
i tend to highlight yours in the chat
that's a really good
call incredibles and team up with big
hero 6.
holding it down with the good side i
would not be surprised if disney ever
decided to go through with that
i wouldn't either honestly it's right in
their backyard like they could easily do
it
they own all those rights don't they
what about um
the next harry potter movie it's jk
rowling versus the transgender community
oh goodness and then it just becomes
some kind of like courtroom drama
yeah or like public written by james
patterson
run away rolling and knees
that's a great great call john thank you
sir anissa's back
a crossover between thank you anissa
crossover between jaby kawai and the
real rejects
wish granted it already exists there are
videos you could find online my dear
dig back into the back catalog shabby
kawai and the reject nation combining
together
we've reacted to debbie coe we've gone
to his channel he's come to this channel
you know when we react to jaby kawaii
i make sure to be as positive as [ __ ]
yeah when he covers anything on this
channel
who's got some like criticism he's got a
full-on breakdown
oh yeah look forward to that eric
eric eric horseman the man with the
horse [ __ ]
the discordo jacks do you call us that
does that you named us john
um i probably wrote it in there
somewhere yeah
this quarter jacksfam rules still can't
think of any crossovers
eric eric just check in every 10 minutes
with a super chat or a streamlab
contribution
with you not able to come up with a
crossover i appreciate that yeah
you i'm sure you can do it by the end of
this live stream even if it's just a
crossover between
orange juice and vodka you've got one
all right i know you've got one in you
thank you eric thank you appreciate the
contribution
um really quick i want to throw us to
the live stream chat okay
for everyone in the chat right now yes
um we're gonna go back to the super chat
just a sec
but i want to see what youtubers you
think should verse each other i mean
[ __ ] we're doing it ksi for slogan paul
it's happening so why youtubers should
verse each other
i want to see the quartering go
toe-to-toe with geeks and gamers
they put them in the ring let's see what
happens
uh uh paul joseph watson versus andy
signor
i want to see shaun c versus anthony
fontana
and
that would be great yes let's do that
no life shack versus i'm dante i should
do
i should do uh oh that'd be fun i should
do uh i should update the thumbnail with
just
a bunch of bunch of youtubers youtubers
on the png but keep it going guys
markiplier versus jack skeptic guys
that'd be a lot of fun
ooh matpat versus markiplier in the ring
would actually be a great one
jeremy johns versus eric voss uh oh
uh oh jeremy versus tyrone versus the
normies tyrone versus angry joe
who's superman are you in an auction
shot oh we got another crossover another
cross over here
do i hear a new rockstars do i hear new
rockstars do i hear soups do i hear
soups do i hear cosmic one
cosmic windup is everything always what
do we got here greg
jacksepticeye uh let's bring this
tyrone versus on i hate everything
versus great grace randolph
ooh john campia versus jay washington i
would love to see that go toe-to-toe in
the ring
i would too i think that jay why should
be like i'm gonna beat your ass
and john campbell be like no i don't
want to fight
i don't want to fight
here's what i'm going to do to you
and then you got rob over on the side
just the color commentary
oh no real rejection grace randolph
should have a team up one i
agree i will not give in to any of these
verses unless i actually hang out with
these people or talk with them on the
phone
cinema versus dead meat roll
you want to be able to pre-discuss yeah
it's different when i'm making fun of
other people
but i don't want to get in trouble with
fellow friends who are like
yo what the [ __ ] you say about me man no
man they're just a joke on a live stream
you want to fight for real uh wolf pack
gaming wolf pack you're part of our wolf
pack and that makes me very happy
and also you're a gamer and hey man
there's video games versus copyright i'm
sorry i just kind of
i totally got distracted you're breaking
from this
i'm breaking from the super chat i'm
sorry i love the graphic i know i made a
mistake so you're you're allowed ten
more mistakes now
with uh wolfpack gaming thank you dude
uh
i've seen your name before let's get to
know each other better but really
appreciate it it's good to know
thank you for contributing in the stream
so sexy
i'll let you [ __ ] on my chest one day i
like that
i like that [ __ ] on my chest with all
the video games we have today
what would you like to see in a movie
you know character development
some good cinematography yeah you know
like a plot that doesn't devolve into
just like
exposition puzzles focused movies
something that's not setting up a sequel
but just really caring about its own
film a visual color palette that's not
all gray brown
oh oh oh oh with all the video games
today what would we like to see
of like which one to adapt it into a
movie got it
got it okay here we go all right i got
the best pick for you
i got the best one for you
dance dance revolution
versus no dancing which one would you
like to see adapted into a movie oh just
adapt it all right yes dance dance
revolution for sure
that move that movie exists yeah what's
it called it's called the fb
oh is it yeah [ __ ] all right yeah no no
i got another one just like the one we
tried
okay i got another one don't worry i
want to see
i want to see turok the dinosaur oh
that'd be cool
truck crossing over into jurassic world
oh
tourette crossing over into jurassic
park wouldn't work nope but turok the
dinosaur hunter crossing over into
jurassic world
i like with the way they set up jurassic
world three
it would make sense to have a turok in
there it would be freaking awesome
just some terrible cliche
racist stereotype native american dude
named turak
fighting dinosaurs in like los angeles
played by
liam hemsworth that would be jake
gyllenhaal
cool i would love that in fact i'm gonna
piggyback off you and weirdly i've
always wanted to do a dino crisis
adaptation
uh or uh uh devil may cry similar to the
same developers but yeah i would love to
see one of those come to the big screen
i think toxic pump says you suck and
then
watch this now he's blocked oh
what do you know psych um
so let's see here like godzilla in the
jurassic park world i'm surprised we
haven't said that
but yeah that's what i would pick man
thanks wolf pack gaming
never lose your nerd you know what i
love about never lose your nerd
the name that he has here because think
about it there's a time where like being
called a nerd was a
[ __ ] insult like you [ __ ] nerd now
now the nerds are the bullies yeah
what's up
never lose your nerd we got the
antagonistic qualities now
look at that your power yeah the power
the upper hand now you can guilt people
instead of guilting people for not being
able to catch a pass you can guilt them
for not having read
all the issues of that arc all right
what did he say
jedi and sith versus marvel
you mean he means captain marvel
or ms marvel yeah or marvel
um ooh actually captain marvel versus
miss marvel i already want to see that
but okay jedi and sith
versus marvel i i what does that mean
see the thing is i think that would work
i feel like the jedi and sith would be
able to subsist however
i don't think like there are definitely
characters in the marvel universe that i
think could definitely wipe out the sith
and the jedi however
if they're up against the right people
you know like their their range and
their lightsaber you know it might work
um i just think you got to have the jedi
and it's just
i think what you really want to star
wars and and marvel to cross over
is get those episode one like senatorial
hearings but apply
that to the superheroes you should be
writing
for the big leagues i definitely
should especially with those
inspirations chill level tv i get
chiller
just seeing your name and more on the
level thank you chill level tv
again so consistent with being here in
our streams
really do appreciate it buddy very much
so um and just you know you are
a gentleman who provides a lot of
relaxation in my personal life
you're so gentle ash williams and negan
or ash and deadpool cross
oh i don't know if i can handle an ash
and deadpool crossover that might be too
much
that might be too much so much meta
sarcasticness happening in that oh my
god i don't know if i can handle that if
you could find a way to like make it so
so that each of their signature blends
of meta like
crash together and crack and like break
the movie into like a third
even more meta layer i think like the
thing is i
i would be really excited but i think
the the
margin for success is so small that i
would be so worried because i think
there is a version of that that would be
amazing and many versions of that that
would be
annoying my god you know i am i i'm
loving this topic so much all right but
ash versus negan
ooh you know i would love to see that
you met lucy yeah and now she'll be like
you're a pretentious jackass or
something
that's a stupid bad habit bad boy how
about this uh
james uh whatever i [ __ ] it up all
right but thank you chill level tv
chase gardner cg is that your lovely
face
i like to see your lovely face one time
chase
um i couldn't fix my toilet and chase
came by and just unplunged that whole
thing for me so thank you dude well
done chase is a great guy gotta respect
him i do
people i know on us on a very personal
level get the best compliments
harry potter and mission impossible
crossover
ethan hunt needs to find horcruxes quick
i just wanna oh
yes yes he's gonna somehow they
managed to make like a nuclear doomsday
device that has horocruxes you have to
break in order to dismantle it
we need that and the only way to do it
is for
ethan hunt to go through platform nine
and three quarters
and go find harry potter i just wanna
see him running through hogwarts
yeah that'd be so fun yeah
you cover all the hair he goes to all
his advantages he gets his wand
finds out that he's got magic abilities
after all
i want i want oh that's great thank you
chase guard
i adore this should we do one or two
more uh yeah all right movies oh my god
i'm looking at deadeye 616. thank you so
much for such a major contribution oh my
goodness
all righty uh first we got movies are
for life
one and they are for life they're for
livelihood
and you make me feel lively just seeing
your names thank you
you know what's great about covid
nothing actually
but you know what's good about this time
is it gives it time to catch up on some
[ __ ]
this is the truth this is the truth and
movies are for life says
spider-man man spider versus blade
i would i would just want man spider at
all i just want a man spider to to show
up
in the universe i feel like spider-man
depending on what
stage he's at in his peter parker
journey or even miles morales could
easily kick blade's ass
yeah i said it can you just web him in
the face i said it
just like web him in the face and like
you know knock him out or call tony
stark for some help
yeah yeah he has the glasses yeah you
know
uh thank you movies are for life shouts
out to canada
appreciate you rory nolan rory
christopher jonathan nolan you know one
time
um i i i i
one time i bumped into rory at a ralph's
parking lot
because my like he saw that i couldn't
start my car and he
jump-started my car by wiring up to his
nipples so thank you rory for being you
you got enchanting nipples his
suggestion is
or her suggestion rory could be a girl
could be anybody in that case
i take that whole joke back kaiju
monster versus because if you're a god
it's okay cashew monster versus
independence day aliens hmm
i think the kaiju the guy would step on
that
independence alien unless you had one
that was kaiju sized here's how i know
the kaiju monsters would destroy those
independence day aliens
there's one scene in the whole movie
that that lets me know this
okay okay it's when will smith
punches punch the alien who who's not
who's not who's in his shell protective
gear
thing and just punches him
twice and says welcome to earth
[ __ ] drags him across the desert
i'm pretty sure if will smith can punch
him
i'm sure guys you could [ __ ] those
independence day aliens up
no problem yeah yeah that's a good
that's a good point
but thank you thank you just the same
deadeye 616.
this [ __ ] like what's crazy
about this guy is
he's not in our live streams all the
time and i rarely even see deadeye 616
um in the chat either
but every once in a while he just shows
up and he's like
got a fat super chat for you i [ __ ]
love it
thank you just like what's up i'm back
boom like a pam you dead i did thank you
deadeye 616.
deadpool kills the dc universe
i that would be a blast i want it
i want it cheers shots fired in deadpool
2 when he says like are you sure you're
not from the dc
universe that's the cable oh you're dark
yeah yeah
oh that would be so much like i i i
weirdly the way how dc's
uh uh handles their properties hey dead
eyes so he's in the chat what's up buddy
hi the way uh dc handles their
variety of shows and movies combining
the weirdness
i feel like they're more likely to agree
to do some random one-off
of deadpool kills dc universe than
marvel is to agree to do some random
one-off
ted pull kills i got it yeah i gotta
imagine that's the major gift of the dc
eu's like
really scatter shot entry into the world
because now the possibilities are so
wide
you know i mean even in watching doom
patrol season one you have
the villain mr nobody is like a deadpool
character in a way
so um yeah i could see i i i could see
it working thanks dead
616. thank you kindly um yeah i'm trying
to make sure we don't fall like
exceptionally behind on the
on this on on the contributions today
because that's the situation we often
run into we're about 35 minutes behind
right now
all right let's do one more here where
are we at where we at oh we gotta go up
john help me help me out please i love i
love you john
i love you too there we go dragon
soldier dragon soldiers back
if we're doing shows how about chuck
cross over with numbers
you know i i used to watch
numbers and i liked that show and i
saw some promos for chuck and even
though numbers isn't quite as humorous
as chuck
i think it could be pretty fun i i liked
uh
numbers and i like to cast that show so
i'm a big believer in the yes and
however i'm going to no but you chuck
should be in the show supernatural
because he gets along with those guys
am i thinking of the same chuck
wait i'm i'm thinking of chuck from the
show chuck yeah who plays zachary levi
yeah and zachary levi gets a lot oh
he does yeah you meant chuck from
supernatural no i
was like chuck oh yeah he does get along
with this because of course he shocked
from super chuck
from the show chuck you should cross
over into supernatural
that's a good call i don't agree maybe
it's been done before no it hasn't but
basically it was zachary levi with them
working together done before
but i think that would be a perfect
crossover now that i'm on your page i
agree
and princess unicorn nipples you know
why we love you princess unicorn
i just love saying your name and
thinking about what a terrible father
i'll one day be
when i am my daughter princess unicorn
nipple i'm gonna say my son
princess what's going wrong princess
unicorn nipples i heard you i heard you
screaming
and are your princess unicorn nipples
okay
i'm talking about your mentality and
your soul
and what's great about that is is is
that child's
uh uh you know monogram or you know
their initials would be
p-u-n for pun the monogram with the
camera monahan
again sometimes they just come to you
you know yeah
you gotta yeah sometimes you just get
they just show up in the noggin
sometimes they just knock knock and when
they knock knock you out let the devil
in
yes malevolent as i've ever been all
right john
all right all right here we go oh ooh
ooh this is a crossover
okay we got some streamlabs out there i
want some of these labs it's the right
spot to put it oh yeah
oh yeah all right queen anisa queen
anissa back at it
also did you hear about the spy thriller
coming with ryan gosling and chris evans
directed by the
russo brothers they said they are trying
to do a james bond franchise
thoughts yes i have many thoughts this
is the best mashup of white people that
come together in a long time
chris and ryan i i watched recently the
chris
evans and paul rudd actors on actor
which by the way i think is so much
better
via zoom you think like obviously the
qual
i don't know if you guys have seen
actors on actors have you seen that
it's just actors [ __ ] each other on
camera the whole whole time they're
literally all
others
on actors is like a real personal
interview and there was something that
felt like
it felt exceptionally pretentious when
they're in person
but for some reason when you're watching
it on zoom
it feels no it feels a lot more natural
and like a real conversation and
i'm not sure what it is that's that's
causing it to be that way because
they're filming from homes and they're
just like chatting
i think it's the tangibility it's like
it's rougher around the edges it's not
like oh there's a live band and
everything's hyper produced
and uh watching chris evans and paul
rudd's made me just love chris evans
that much more chris evans has like done
so many of those actors on actors
and ryan gosling i feel like has
chemistry with
anyone it seems like any any movie ryan
gosling does that's the other thing
that's great about him especially in
movies that require more of his
personality to shine as opposed to just
being stoic and staring at [ __ ]
like then especially the nice guy i feel
i really
oh yeah when i'm more excited for
anything else more than the movie
is the the uh interviews of chris evans
and ryan gosling together yes
i feel like they've been side by side
very very very
funny yeah and and any interviews they
do together so yeah i'm really excited
for that movie
agreed agreed okay we got scrapzilla 54
with a very
cool name scrapzilla love your name 1954
is the year
jackie chan was born so i
instantly gravitate towards you
scrapzilla
boom scrapzilla says the ultimate
cinematic duo's crossover j
and silent bob meet bill and ted meet
wayne and garth
meet r2 and c3po meet mulder and scully
meet cheech and chong meet ree
riggs and murtagh meet brennan and dale
me doc and marty meet jules and vincent
meet harry and lloyd
what i love about yours scrapzilla is
it the genre mashup of them just makes
no sense
it's that's what makes it that much more
appealing we tried writing
a around the time of like those movies
like uh [ __ ]
uh meet the spartans were coming out or
whatever we tried one writing one that
was going to be like a spoof of movies
like cloverfield and i am legend we were
the teenagers
clutter field was the name flutterfeel
is what we were trying to write and
that's what your crossover idea reminds
me of
is just like i think of clutter
they don't need to be jokes just make
references who the [ __ ] cares
oh god i i learned there is a vast
chasm of quality in the parody movie
market erica tuesday
erica tuesday with her erica tuesday
what
patent satan tip erica artica
it's time to redeem with a genuine
compliment
now erica look out now let's do that
let's do that let's do that
[Music]
erica is incredibly intelligent
wonderfully creative super insightful
hilarious at the same time weird and
zany and all the right charming
appealing ways
um and she has one of the biggest hearts
of anybody i know huge empath
mm-hmm super funny i just gotta say like
super funny
and she's someone who like when you
listen to her
talk it's she has such a fascinating
thought process
and you can see why she's such a
wonderful creative yeah oh
dude you shouldn't i don't want to
embarrass you i met her
at an event where she
was killing it with an animation
property all right
there you go there you go there you go
winning the game
are you here erica oh my goodness erica
too she's got uh she just acquired
something pretty sweet
which is like a the holy grail
the ark of the covenant
oh yes but yeah no shouts out to erica
because erica is
radical what'd you say not a crossover
so much but i wonder what would happen
if you put all 45 presidents aged at
their time in office
in a hunger game style dome and let them
all duke it out
who would be the first to go who would
be the one president to rule them all
who pierce jimmy carter
appears to be the first to go because i
don't know who pierce is and i just
learned we had a president named pierce
oh good now i'm thinking of chevy chase
from community i was taking a pierce
brosnan
president pierce brosnan would be very
suave and i'd listen to him
weirdly i feel like one that would
actually have a fighting
chance on the republican side is trump
because he's so aggressive he's so
ruthless he's
so aggressive he's so unscrupulous too
like no no
dirty trick is dirty just too dirty i
think jfk would [ __ ] up and try and
negotiate his way out
i do not want to fight ask not what this
battle can do for you
[Laughter]
i gotta i gotta i think taft uh you know
just by sheer force of mass would stand
a chance
or i would go off of raccadillo's
comment and i feel like
everyone would gain up everyone would be
like let's cut out trump first and then
let's talk it out
let's see where we go from here
i wonder i wonder where w would line up
or like obama i wonder where they would
end up oh bob play it smart
obama would know how to be like sneaky
obama would [ __ ] like embrace the
jungleness of it and like crawl oh
obama would be there to be the katniss
of the team where it's like
figure that [ __ ] out i don't care if
there's only one winner like whoever's
my ally who's been good to me like we're
all gonna win together they would know
obama killed everyone when they find
these dead bodies because he'd piss on
their bodies
that's just an obama thing it's marking
his territory
thank you erica hey we got one and this
is it
thank you mr horseman appreciate it big
time buddy a good pick eric
oh train what a good one
train to busan
the last civilization train bound on
earth good one
plus a zombie apocalypse what's not to
love
i would love to s i wish snow peer
surrendered that where they get to the
tre
they get on the other side of the train
and then it's just
[ __ ] there's a bunch of zombies oh no
no no one told us about this oh that
would be grand
but which version of that one character
do we keep do we keep uh
jeffrey wright or david diggs because
now there's a tv show you know
defeat diggs yeah that's true and
jeffrey right [ __ ] it we're crossing
over
train to busan
all the train piercers oh man that's a
great one train piercer
busan
i guarantee it okay i'm going to add one
more to that train to busan snow piercer
and the girl on the train
and murder on the orient express all
right okay
let's uh let's do one more and then
let's go back to the chat and see all
the crazy pics you guys have been
contributing in the lives
our lovely flev is back defenders
to cross over with the mcu for real this
time put matt murdock in the next spidey
film jessica jones versus captain marvel
luke cage and black panther
not just because he's black but because
they have
similar morals danny rams because they
have similar black worlds
danny rand i don't know yourself
what are you doing uh
shang shang for danny rand um
yeah dana and shane would make perfect
sense okay i'm going to break this down
for you
danny rand i i just so
i haven't heard laugh as michael jackson
i haven't heard it a long time a long
time
all right let's do this matt murdock in
the next spidey film okay yeah them
teaming up
jessica jones vs cat marvel while i
prefer
jessica jones way over captain marvel
captain america just has to like stick
her hand out didn't you answer her
yeah do a jet beam and there you go luke
cage versus black panther
ooh you know i feel like luke cage could
power his way through that one
and danny rand versus shane chi one's
asian and knows martial arts
let's go with shang chi even though that
movie's not out
yeah i think chiang chi would probably
win absolutely
absolutely all right guys okay we'll get
back to the super chats and the stream
labs in a second thank you to everyone
who's been contributing
so far during that um you guys have
everyone's picks have been awesome tm i
i agree for the presidential crossover
definitely gotta knock out the slave
owning presidents first
all right let's see what we got in here
let's guys okay i saw
one that said uh home alone crossed over
with die hard
which i love oh you could have kevin
mcallister
working with john mclean in like a hotel
yeah make it like they're trying to get
out and then mcallister's like
no let's bring the fight to us yeah we
gotta lure them in
die home die home
and then the sequel will be called die
alone
die home die alone and it's still the
wet band it's
john mcclane versus the wet band all
right let's see here let's see here
kim possible and agents of shield uh ooh
okay i'll be fun red dead and resident
evil i think would be fun
scoob versus the box off oh power ranger
uh sylvester power rangers team up with
fast and furious that would be a blast
and then the cars can be a megazord yes
exactly
yes and then they verse the transformer
and then
dominic tereto can take over for zordon
in the giant tomb with the face
that works yeah uh
scooby doo versus teen titans yeah uh
teen titans would win
yeah if they had to fight i mean if
we're talking about like the scoob one
maybe they have a chance but come on
let's face it the teen ties would knock
them out i see sailor moon versus
captain marvel vs powerpuff girls which
i i like
uh i i'm not familiar with the sailor
moon level of powers are they that
powerful
like like could they take out a captain
marvel i think the powerpuff girls would
have a hard time with captain marvel
a little bit my girlfriend recently got
a sailor moon makeup kit
and she's constantly singing the sailor
moon theme song and she stressed the
[ __ ] out
about making sure i was at the mailbox
for when that makeup box
came in
that way no one sees it complex
immediately
before anybody puts it on since it's
arrived it's here
just go get it it sold out right away
and i was one of the lucky ones again
i congratulate i want to try some now
you're really selling this makeover kit
ooh lucifer morningstar and supernatural
uh that would be great
i'm trying to go back to the uh the ones
where the youtubers
where's the camera where's the one with
the the youtubers
i saw emergency awesome versus john
campia yeah that'd be so funny
oh who would i guess who would win that
i guess campia
has who has solid more solid sources
that's who it is
[Laughter]
red letter media versus nostalgia critic
i think nostalgia
will win if even if it was a two-on-one
fight
in a boxing ring because that's from
imagining this
nostalgia critic has so much more energy
than both of them
weirdly i feel like nostalgic critic
would win on either one-on-one
but if it was a group against nostalgia
critic not
i mean partly yes because he would be
outnumbered but for some reason i feel
like the red letter media like
sense of uh that that mean streak
in there in their in their dna would
come out and they might be able to
triumph
if we're talking about red letter media
versus nostalgia critic here's what it
would be like
because you have you have mike from red
letter media
okay here's what i'm imagining you know
like in in video games like injustice
or mortal kombat you'll have your
characters who can do a lot of combos
and then you get like the big buff guy
and you play as him you're like this guy
can't can barely do
[ __ ] he's heavy he sucks yeah he's kind
of nobody
can do anything but if you land one hit
with that guy
it has so much power damage yeah
and that's what mike versus nostalgia
critic would be i think nostalgia critic
could get so many more hits in there but
mike would keep standing
that he would just have one hit yeah and
then bam it would be like a lot of power
damage could occur
it would be mr blanket versus nostalgic
yeah yeah
and i think if jay were to get in the
ring i think he would he would be the
surprise scrapper because he's in the
like you know exploitation like you know
freaky gory movies and stuff like i feel
like there's some edge there
who's another buff youtuber because you
got john flickinger
yeah no no i'm saying he's the only
buffy evan dollard evan
who's that who's like a popular movie
youtuber
buff popular movie youtubers does chris
jericho count now that he's in the
showdown
i'm not sure yeah
um that's a great question buff
youtubers
actually i'd love to see christian
harloff and i'd love to see schmoe's no
get in the ring
with [ __ ] red letter media yeah team
match i like it i want it you hear me
harloff
um i mean you know corey at double
toasted has
some muscles on his arms i think he's he
looks a little bit fit
all right let's see here al bundy meets
charlie hopper all right
tony montana versus walter white ooh
light from death note versus sherlock
holmes uh that's
cheating i mean he did
l is basically sherlock holmes all right
okay what about
what about all right let me just find
another one i like it
i like i like light and sherlock because
i want to see it anyway
i'm just afraid that the death note
would trump everything
real rejects versus double toasted
i'd stand a chance i'd stand to i'd be
able to stand fighting john will go down
right away
yeah john will go down right away yeah i
don't i don't know if i'd be able to
fight them i'd just be like
too much like oh senpai john cringe is
too many things you think he's going to
be able to stand up
at this moment he just go
no no no no no
it's like an amuse like oh no like you
know i don't know
that's how i interpret it you're scared
of everything john
ooh all my versus captain america oh my
god all right
all mine in his prime would dominate
captain america leatherface versus wrong
turn i think would be fun
because long wrong turn is inspired by
who would win leatherface or
mary poppins you know
i think mary might be able to edge it
out if she can just keep that range
advantage just flying on that umbrella
so we can't reach her
that'd be fun i think it would be all
right itchy and scratchy versus red and
stimpy what a great call
there you go boom see i'm maria hammond
thank you mary what's up maria
john work with john wick versus ethan
hunt john work
i i feel like i gotta give it to ethan
hunt on that one
you know i feel like he could outwin him
i feel like ethan hunt yeah
with would just i don't know he's all
he's everywhere at once
like john wick can like be a ghost ethan
hunt would have some kind of crazy ass
surveillance [ __ ] where it's like you
know
john wick wouldn't even see him i agree
with this humphrey okay
john wick versus john mccl john wick
would easily oh yeah
ooh john humphrey versus bucky barnes
bucky barnes anytime you put john in the
fight he's gonna lose let's just give
john someone he can beat
[ __ ] john john humphrey versus
daniel day lewis from my left foot
versus mclovin
john versus yeah just all the
wheelchair-bound characters and
versus eric would not be cool no team up
don't fight each other team up and save
the world with your generosities
manage seal two with the kid from
breitbart oh you get the kid from bright
burn to verse henry cavill's superman
there you go ooh i weirdly feel like the
bright burn kid would actually win
uh yeah if he's willing to he doesn't
have any morals
i see uh e ip man versus ethan hunt oh
hey man we would
okay all right all right cool thank you
guys thank you all right
let's not fall too far behind here kill
that overlay there you go
all right i'm just gonna go grab a fan
real fast like an actual
fan and plug it in because getting kind
of hot in here so give me one sec
john pull a fan up on stage hold the
fork down
we are gonna hold the fort and uh i'm
gonna pay
a compliment right here to bradley love
star because you're combining two of the
most beautiful things
on this earth brad pitt
just kidding love and stars loving stars
are two of the most wondrous things
out there and seeing your name bradley
love star
right now just makes me think of
jonathan joestar
because we've been watching jojo's
bizarre adventure
and if you haven't seen that show it's
it's absolutely insane
anyhow i'm gonna wait to read this until
the g train is back in the room
but bradley i appreciate your generosity
and i'm just gonna say it right off the
top
i think batman's gonna win i don't know
i think maybe joker would win but either
way you party on
because greg is almost back to the room
i see uh on this
uh hold on a sec we're gonna go back to
the super chats in a minute but i cannot
ignore
kevin mcallister versus jigsaw i think
that
would be perfect because kevin
mcallister and jigsaw
you know if they could go toe-to-toe
somehow like maybe they're both subject
to each other's trap the thing is
eventually would end in a team-up so you
could get both
you could get your team up you could get
your verses crossover
that ends in a team up and then you've
got
endless potential moving forward
anyway greg how'd you do you find the
fan did you do it
i believed in you and it paid off
all right i'm about to read the super
chat
because i've paid bradley a huge
compliment
hey guys my girlfriend got so mad at me
because she was looking at photos of
some girl
and i was like who's this and i was like
where are you watching look up celebrity
she's like
looking at celebrities i'm like it's
stevie nicks i was like who's stevie
nicks
do you and i'm like do you know who she
is yeah she's she's you know stevie
nicks of like fleetwood
fame and being stevie
i didn't know that oh it's okay you i
don't honestly stay with her
but she was looking up a celebrity
stevie nicks is a celebrity
i mean not as i thought she was just
looking up celebrity photos
oh it's okay i i feel like a lot of
people
in in this generation might not know her
name so i wouldn't feel too bad
all right what do we got next bradley
lovestar
yeah bradley loves [ __ ] great porn
star name oh
look at that all you got to do is change
the first half what a great porn star
four letters and all bradley pornstar
hey guys i'd love to see joaquin
phoenix's joke or go head-to-head
against
heath ledgers or christian bale's batman
party on dudes
oh dude i'm surprised this is the first
joker we've got i'm sorry you know
stevie nixon's
god damn it should have [ __ ] said
that i
i i but you know fleetwood mac's music
i know please listen i think that's the
most important i listen to the song
where you type in
the guardians of the galaxy song
yeah they wrote they wrote that
guardians of the galaxy
song way back um yeah she would kick my
butt lisa marie
olivia versus greg all right
yeah i'm surprised this is the first
joker one we've got in all
stream mm-hmm because we're like oh my
god oh geraldo's or is he larger
but i guess there's been so much fanfic
put towards the joker one
mm-hmm you know um but i mean at this
point like every
halloween party is a is a joke or
crossover yeah exactly
there's so many jokes i'm actually
surprised
um so joaquin phoenix versus heath
ledger
i think i'd be very i'm i'm really
opposed to the idea of walking phoenix's
joker crossing over into a batman movie
yep now let me just say
if robert pattinson's batman movie
presents itself in a way where i could
see joaquin phoenix's arthur fleck
being in that same bat universe
i'd be down to see that
i know i know guys hot takes around here
no one's no one's thought of this yet i
would be open to you
but i'm just saying i mean that's the
thing is yeah if they just draw a tone
that suits it
i would be i would be open to that i it
just yeah it seems so isolated right now
that it doesn't seem possible but i
think keith ledger's joker would win out
of this trio
because he's the one who's willing to
murder you know
batman would have to break his one roof
all right thank you bradley never lose
your nerd back at it again
gears of war versus halo
that's a tough one because i mean part
of me wants to go master chief of course
but
i mean marcus phoenix and those guys are
so beefed out
and roided up and just like hardcore
i feel like i don't know they would
stand a chance um
yeah especially with seeing the comments
the room for that gameplay trailer for
the la for the halo
one oh for infinite i was like i think
gears of wars would have a chance now
cause some people got i was like damn
what's with all the dis i had like an
eighty percent like to dis like ratio on
a gameplay trailer i was like oh that's
pretty
that's that's kind of uh worrisome for a
halo game
was there a specific thing that that
people seemed to dislike about it
or did it just look i don't know i don't
know i was actually pretty taken aback
by how
how limited the dislikes how like how
many dislikes there were
like 80 still a passing grade but it was
like
yeah jeepers all right well you're
talking about kathleen kennedy in that
video
or why the last of us too is actually a
good game oh
oh how did everyone just everyone just
left the stream
uh we got to move on to rackadio
raccadillo
thank you never lose your nerd uh geralt
raccadillo by the way that that that
profile pic
we got to bring it back to that profile
pic i remember that's one of the first
things we ever talked about with you
rickado is one of the few people who if
you just showed me the profile pic
that's not an actual
you know human face but a specific
drawing i would be like
i know that that's wreck a deal right
away yeah i agree
geralt of rivia the witcher with game of
thrones
i mean the witcher the show was
constantly being touted as like the next
game of thrones netflix is game of
thrones
so actually having him show up in like a
game of thrones world the world of that
that seems like it could be a perfect
fit yeah especially with the
supernatural blend and everything
geralt versus the night king or
something
although nah that moment was okay that
was the good moment of season eight
not everyone would agree with you on
that one johnny yeah
good to know i thought it was the one
thing people agreed on
uh racodio raccadillo thank you so much
uh princess unicorn nipples back in
action
i effed up on my super chat
rocketeer and the marvel universe ooh
that would be cool i really think
rocketeer is having a big
like the the present the rocketeer and
the shadow
and it has something to do with like 90s
nostalgia i think because rocketeer was
i believe 91
and shadow i think was it was 94 or 96 i
i constantly
get mixed up you've got the duel of you
have those movies in the 90s and also
the extra nostalgia of them being like
from even earlier
with the serials on the radio and stuff
yeah so if you got the rocketeer yeah
in the marvel universe and timothy
dalton you brought him
back he doesn't know you know he's not
he's not the rocketeer he's just in the
rocketeer
i got that rock hey just bring him
anyway yeah well anytime see
t don't show i'm happy
my bad but hey that would be a fun one
you're a mistake indeed
john's a bit of an alcoholic a lot of
people don't know that i am
that's all i drink give him a shot with
the orange juice and then he drinks beer
and then he does some cocaine
that's right john if your parents are
watching i'm sorry for snitching on you
but i'm really hoping this weekend they
take you to rehab
it's in the works it's gonna happen all
right peter pacheco is back
soul eater versus my hero academia
haven't seen soul eater nor have i i
don't know much about it at all then
let's really comment
on the possibilities and the potential
to pretend like we
really know what we're talking about i'm
gonna do a quick
google over here just to see an image
just so i can familiarize my eyes
then in the meantime i'm gonna look at
some comments here that are
on screen grindelwald versus dumbledore
it's happening already and this is
called fantastic beasts three yeah
get ready for jude law and johnny depp
oh that's the cross that's the team up
that we need the lones cobra
with the crossover of lethal weapon
oh that would be fun
have you seen cobra no i've seen the
stuff cobra is not necessarily what you
would guilt somebody for not having seen
in this day and age
i will okay fair enough yes fair enough
cobra is a classic is it nah it's pretty
terrible
i think it was supposed to be beverly
hills cop three and then he like turned
that script into cobra
wow all right getting that fact way off
i hope that's the right fact
oh oh my i just caught one out of the
corner
django from django one shade in zorro
that would be it one that'd be my my one
right there all right
uh so thank you peter pacheco sorry we
can't comment more on it but i
appreciate you buddy
wolf pack is back wolf pack gaming
deadpool
versus armageddon from x-men
my god john do that thing where you type
obnoxiously
all right it's just i mean it is it's
the construction
defend yourself just do it all right all
right
all right um who am i looking at
armageddon
from x-men you got this john
you got this no or is he
is it just it's all pictures of
apocalypse
apocalypse is is it armageddon another
name for apocalypse i mean yeah but oh
is it armageddon man
oh okay well
we got two super chats in a row where
greg and john
don't really know the characters you're
pitching
so yes definitely want that that's the
beautiful thing about livestreams when
you're
like thanks for the super chat i wish i
could say more
google well you know i've learned here
today that that
armageddon man looks like a cool
character and uh you know this other
show this
this witch soul eater show also has a
cool poster so there you go well thank
you man
deadpool versus anything will work yes
it will
movies are for life this should happen
death
this definitely should happen atomic
blonde versus
john wick i mean
yeah john go sorry i know i was going to
cut you off again my favorite thing to
do
i just say i mean like i i think of that
fight scene alone
from when the in the stairwell just
makes me think of like that could easily
have been the continental
like can you imagine charlie's darren's
character in the continental or
something like that
um i i think that charlize theron
actually you know keanu reeves and
charlie stern did star together in one
movie
way back when do you know that movie
charlie's darren and keanu reeves um
it's called sweet november let's not go
there
all right so sweet november since i've
seen sweet november i think anyway go on
you would know sweet november
i remember it's a very specific plot
okay
i'm gonna do that thing again while you
talk about it but
i watched the old guard recently i gotta
admit wasn't a fan of the movie
all right but charlie's there and i
still think hicks like so
she is it's weird for charlie stern to
be
as famous as she is and yet
i still feel like she's an underrated
talent it's it's
it's this weird thing about her
where everyone knows who everyone knows
who she is she's one of the biggest
stars in the world
yet i still feel like she's not given
the credit for the versatility she can
do
yeah and um like drama comedy
action and because whatever genre you
put her in she's going to excel
in that movie like 99
of the time she will she's to the point
where like anything she gets casted i'm
just confident that yeah she's going to
find a way to embody the role and i'm
going to lose her in it
and i think atomic blonde versus john
wick especially i think she
actually moves better in the i don't
think the fights in old guard are
anywhere near as good as the fights in
atomic blonde
yet at the same time i think did you
watch all the guard yes
i loved it did you really no i thought
it was so bad
i was like this had so much potential i
could go on a whole rant about like
what was good in the ideas and the
concepts that just was not
hidden it for me and i know i'm in the
minority on that
um so what was i trying to say all right
she moves better but i think her form in
fighting
is much better in the old guard than it
was in atomic blonde was like
it's not blonde it seemed like she was
like really loading a lot of her hits
it's like she used to do an elbow strike
you know like an elbow strike you just
go like you'd be fighting you just go in
and she would be like you know
at that movie queue so i think now the
atomic blonde versus john wick would be
even better than
how people wanted it before equalizer
and john wick in the chat i love that
suggestion
also uh no problem lloyd happy to have
made your day a little bit
anissa john john you gotta do this for
her
and just read her comment in your
southern accent anissa has a comment
she wants uh in the southern accent
supernatural and the walking dead
crossover
i know it'd be hard with jdm being on
both shows but i know they'd make it
work
that's uh give some comments joseph
i think you know what supernatural in
the walking dead crossover tonally i
think would work it would just be a
i think that would work tonally i think
sam and dean coming across a group of
those survivors
like the croatoan stuff in the parts of
the show that we've seen up until this
point like i think we've often
name-checked the walking dead as like oh
this kind of reminds me like a walking
dead
uh type scene so uh yeah i think they
would
definitely i think it would be really
funny to see if
they would have to if if negan's or
they'd have to do something about that
about the jdm uh sharing i think that's
a crossover that people have wanted for
such a long time but i don't think even
jensen ackles or jared patalecki like
that idea
i don't know if they would care to do it
i think the idea is a joke yeah
you know true it would have to be just
like a novelty one-off
and maria hammond i see you in the chat
being like people appreciate her
she did win an oscar charlie theron okay
i don't think people appreciate the
amount
of versatility that she still provides i
think people i like
put that at the forefront when it comes
to charlize theron no
i wonder what people do put at the
forefront like the average person who
isn't you know
wishing she had more reindeer games
yeah that's what everyone thinks about
with charlie stern she can't get out of
that reindeer game shadow
i'll let her out eric's back
eric armageddon versus 20 armageddon
i think you meant twenty versus 2012
versus
geostorm climate change hashtag climate
change is
real [ __ ] with that movie it would just
be storms crashing into each other
and then people doing the same like oh
god chaos somehow roland emmerich would
make it about like
eight different families yes
one loony individual yeah we got one's
john cusack ones like nicholas cage one
is you know tom cruise or somebody i
don't know like a war of the worlds era
tom cruise
they were also in the devil's advocate
that's ripe let's just talk about
charlie starring for the rest of this
i'm sorry i'm sorry i i looked over at
the chat for just a second and
i saw danny debs wrote ving rhames
versus a newborn baby
why why would you want that not but i
don't
chase gardner chase gardner thank you
chase
inception and tenant crossover it's
already happened
tomorrow
let's just sit in silence for the rest
of the stream shall we god
is
inception versus tenant crossover i
honestly i i'm not expecting this but i
wouldn't be ultimately surprised if they
had some kind of connection you know it
would be fun
oh there's all sorts of things that
might be fun if
[Laughter]
jumping on a trampoline would be fun
riding in a go-kart
if you took the uh it was speaking of
nolan films if you took
the prestige versus what is the [ __ ] is
that edward norton magic movie
the okay the illusionist is a movie that
that weirdly like my family is really
into and pulls out like once every
couple years yes
so if you have the illusionist versus
the prestige
yes those magicians going toe-to-toe
like someone said in the chat earlier
doctor strange versus constantine yeah
man magic wizardry conjurers
working together or fighting each other
that those always sound like the best
kind of crossovers to me yeah cause you
could just do
let's say usually have like sarcastic
quippy personalities
and then they gotta go toe-to-toe with
one another and who knows the most
knowledge and stuff and then they would
respect each other in the end those are
always the best
hellboy is a baby versus jack jack on
fire that's a great comment i
do love that comment thank you also
chase gardner let's go to the
next next super chat one more yes we'll
maybe do some stream labs
uh what do we got what do we got what do
we got oh man have we fallen behind
again
we are i really thought i was on top
almost an hour behind
alto are we really voltai this is from
531
jesus alto voltaire vol
voltage at some point i want to have a
clarity on if i'm saying that terribly
or not but alto
i just like looking at your name i
appreciate the suggestions you bring to
us every week
alto i mean that's a that's a voice
register you are like
music to my ears alto you're really
reaching for the compliment john i
appreciate that i'm reaching
earl jones and james morgan
one still photo of a space to
our narration one of those was morgan
freeman
yes you said james morgan i said james
earl jones and morgan freeman you said
james earl jones and james morgan who's
james morgan i don't know his name is
boring
but james earl jones and jay and morgan
freeman would be great
actually look what
with the covet happening what is the
chip chin what's everyone talking about
what is the chip channel i don't know
i was talking about it all right chip
chins okay
why haven't james earl jones uh is he
still he's the library
and morgan freeman started a podcast
together again
or an asmr channel what are the other
i i would listen to both if if they did
it
like why haven't the john oh you gotta
i'm trying to solve the chip chin what
are you talking about apparently you had
a chip on your like a little like a
piece of a chip
has got a piece of your protein this
point of the livestream
i don't i don't see it though i don't i
think your chin's just fine all right
james earl jones and morgan freeman
together on a podcast would be
incredible
yes or an asmr or them just guest
starring together for no good reason on
joe rogan's podcast would be the
greatest thing in the world
them just making love to each other yes
imagine those
just the voices without words do you
like that i like that a lot
do you like that baby do you like that
baby
i like that very much
i i wish i had half the the just booming
quality of a james earl jones voice i
understand john
uh i mean let's cap this off with anissa
because it is pretty crisp
real rejects versus double toasted that
crossover
is in reality my my sister oh yeah we're
always competing with double toasted
in fact they're always wanting to go
toe-to-toe with us that's right they're
threatened they're always like damn
real rejects are getting more views on
this same subject than us yeah how could
they
what is where's the chip in my beard are
they [ __ ] with us
this must be some discord thing it must
be i hate that discord
god damn all these guys [ __ ] discord
with their inside
we're gonna have like a ksi style fan
page where people just like
[ __ ] on us uh scrapzilla 54.
that's a cool name we've yeah we've
commented we did
john terminator memory terminator planet
of the apes and godzilla
uh apes worship kong skynet builds
mechagodzilla and the humans have to
rely on godzilla for survival oh
wow i don't like that [ __ ] you should be
right i like it
that is that is a blog line right there
that's an imdb
log line right i love skynet
perfectly pitched perfect that's try
that in an elevator and see who you get
interested
and then if you you throw in kanye west
in there
you got yourselves a box office hit
right now here's a question
let's let's let's start a betting pool
what's gonna be the first
movie to have president kanye in it
somewhere even just as a joke
uh there's what
what john someone said there's a ghost
behind me anyway
eric was here i like that one scrapzilla
thank you thank you that's very that's a
really fun one
that's that's definitely in one of the
mvp eric horseman
i was waiting for someone to say this
homelander versus superman homelander is
one of my favorite villains to ever
emerge from television even though i
know he's from the comics but to emerge
from television
and for the fact that he is like part of
uh you know like
inspired by like a mainly superman but
like a commentary on it
yeah i i mean that would be a total
blast to watch
oh i don't i don't know why i went into
this bird voice just now oh yeah
i'd love to watch a homelander right now
you just watch some kills
hey guys i don't know if we've uh
updated you on this hashtag
john is watching the boys john is up to
how far are you into the boys i'm on
episode five you're in episode five so
how many episodes were
in that season i forgot eight so i'm i'm
i'll be done over the weekend
so we say you're on episode five meaning
you you still have to watch after i
gotta finish
episode five okay i'm part way into
episode all right so john will finish
this in about three months
it's yeah yeah it's about accurate
but right now i'm enjoying it really
great stuff
you guys really great recommendation no
i i just got through the fourth episode
and there is a moment that you actually
told me to look out for and and when it
when that sequence came that plane
sequence came up
uh i haven't felt that combination of
emotions
i'm not sure ever so yeah i'm really
enjoying it so far
uh yes yeah that's right he's into the
boys
he's into the boys weirdly i think
homelander would win just because he's
he just he so amoral
john's not gay he's super gay let's
let's look
at that straight all right don't don't
get twisted all right
he's not gay he's gayer queen anisa in
here saying uh
john versus greg because greg has no
fighting background
at all and would not have an advantage
my money is on
john and you know what i love about this
comment is the pure
lack of irony or sarcasm it's it's
sincere
did you know john actually won a gold
medal when he was in tae kwon do for how
far did you get in taekwondo you got the
green belt
uh green double stripe just below red
yeah green double straight just blow red
that's my that's my neck to me i wish
you would talk like this if there's a
chip in your brain
just before i don't know like
john got a gold medal with doing a for
uh a specific type of uh
with a screw not a squish a bow yeah it
was a bow
big old stick yeah single staff there
was a time where john could do some type
of martial art
i'm pretty good with the bo staff
which is true i have it still in fact
i think out of all the weapons bo staff
is the one that if you learn some
some maneuvers with it it's really that
that is like the equivalent to picking
up a bicycle in a way if you know how to
ride a bike i think i feel like
um the other ones i think will be a
little bit harder to remember
but by the way i love in this chat that
someone just said
anton sugar versus walter white thanks
james wright
that would work i like it i like that
combo actually that might be my favorite
walter white
uh thus far oh yeah have you heard my
dexter one
oh that's right that's my second
favorite walter white thus far
might be uh who we got who we got nerf
mac
we got nerf mac in the chat nerf mac
i like nerf guns and macaroni and cheese
so i love you
character crossovers jason bourne and
james bond
cool yes we've covered that bonstone
nerf mac i love your name
you make um you make me miss big macs dc
versus marvel
of course lou bloom nightcrawler and
travis
pickle taxi driver imagine
contracting him to drive him around town
to [ __ ] bye lloyd
yeah that would be a fun one and that we
should greenlight that because de niro
is still alive
han solo and indiana jones
if like the aliens actually came back
and took him to space
indiana would win you know what i think
he would
you know how i know indiana will win
it's easy just reference scenes he
survived a nuclear blast by hiding in a
refrigerator at the ripe age
of a hundred and seven in kingdom of the
crystal skull
so i i think uh indiana would beat han
solo he definitely did that
vincent and vic vega the pulp fiction
and reservoir dogs characters yes
classic
gay perry and larry and harry lockhart
meet jackson
healey in holland march
[Music]
wait a minute wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait that's from the
nice guys are you like super drunk or
something right now why aren't you
why aren't you staying focused with me i
am i was focusing on okay you're only at
the hour
seven minutes i was focusing on harry
and jackson all right
i mean jackson and holland jesus christ
john i'm trying to i'm trying to make
sure
we're staying on topic here and now we
everyone in the chats can
look at the live stream everyone
everyone's everyone's bitching about you
i have been canceled for this everyone's
commenting about you right now
i'm sorry guys can't
get john to shut up i appreciate that
nerf mac and then he also says my two
favorite nostalgia critic reviews are
max
payne and michael bay's pearl harbor
i've seen both of those those are great
picks thank you for sharing that
i'm going to have to pull those reviews
up all right
let's see here we got flex my last
suggestion is psych
monk crossover it's 4 a.m here i have to
say good night
good night appreciate you being here my
friend i'm gonna look up what your time
zone is but yeah i think my
from what i know about them i haven't
watched really either of them but i know
a lot of fans who have like described
the shows and been like you would love
these
john has cancelled parties happening in
the live stream chat
oh i got my own cancel party hashtag
sean if you get cancelled that would be
so great for me
because then i could do a video about it
and it would get
so many views oh yeah john if we can get
john canceled
before the weekend is over yeah then i
could do a video
oh my god and i could be like i had no
idea
who is that guy who's that guy who does
all those like think pieces about like
the
this is how shane dawson like ended his
career you would make one of those about
me
yeah yeah i'd be like just because i
hang out with the guy
six hours five days a week and seven to
eight hours on saturday nights
i had no idea he was this horrible per
john mm-hmm we got to get you cancelled
it would do great
gotta get you canceled okay i know it's
not good for your well-being
but it would you gotta figure out it
would be good for the channel i
you know for like a day to get those
views i'm giving i would be like oh [ __ ]
long-term results not good i am giving
in to that
i agree tom cruise versus gay thoughts
that's a great one in the livestream i
just got it yeah i couldn't let that one
go
soul skier in 1999 soul scare 1999
haven't heard from you in a while buddy
glad to have you
back here i think if i'm not mistaken
uh solskier may have joined our patreon
about time but i'm not 100
sure there's an sj uh screen name that i
think might be you
uh ethan hunt and jason bourne
david webb uh would be an unfathomable
force
terrorists would have uh to be ethereal
or cosmic
douches to even have a fighting chance
love the show guys been a while since i
got to catch you live well
i'm glad you got to catch us this time
that's what i was pointing out because i
know your name
yeah um so david webb would be an
unfathomable force oh that's jason
bourne yeah
okay that's his real name i thought he
was going into a completely different
thing that flew over my head
um yeah i think jason bourne would
definitely beat ethan hunt
i think jason bourne could yeah i mean
he's he's just like so shrewd and
and a loner i think that's like
part of the the thing that'll clinch it
for him is that he's like a full-on kind
of
just nomad at this point like you rejoin
him and jason bourne and like just what
he does for fun is just like have
fist fights in the desert i love
uh how eric and the chat said i just
can't say greg is canceled
thank you eric you're a real friend
but everyone remember we're canceling
john
during this stream oh yeah that's you
gotta cancel cultures
to be taken seriously i deserve it i
deserve to get canceled
oh b rabbit from eight mile is in venom
jesus said
john always makes apology videos
every video i release is an apology
video
i got something to apologize for every
day dread team's up with the kingsmen
we i feel like we got to find out like
the perfect place for the kings right
now
celine from underworld versus jerry from
fright night
that would be fun dude these are like
hurting my head with the amount that
we're getting right now
mm-hmm all right okay cool guys we gotta
wrap this stream up soon
yeah we do s-o-n i tried to make
you know anytime i eat something
someone's saying that i have a chip in
my beard you know what
i'm not a fan of this comment i gotta
say all right making fun of john's one
thing but making fun of me is a whole
other topic
you know what i think they're doing gee
i think they're joshing you i think they
are
basically going with every time that you
have put up one of those little things
in a video that goes like i know i have
something in my beard and i think
they're trying to trick you into
thinking that you always
wait wait wait wait but it's not racist
right josh and someone
no okay then you could do it i just did
it i just don't know what's racist
anymore is it racist to josh somebody i
thought josh
was just messing with you i was at
trader joe's the other day josh is a
white guy named and i was like can i
can i get some traitor
the entire time and they're like we
don't have those anymore
i'm like why they're like cause it's
trader jose's
they don't like change the name for
every different like
wait so you don't know about this i
didn't know they they stopped
at all no john it's still there oh
we're not gonna make out where did that
come from
i'm eating some nature valley granola
protein
you just make out already danny debs no
i'm just making fun of people where
everything seems racist these days
everything is racist a little bit
everyone's a little bit racist do you
guys think the trader joe should have
changed that
that thing will they change it too
did they just change it to trader joe's
yeah i'm not sure
all right let's wrap up the last of the
super chats and then we're gonna do
a quick go through and like with all the
weird [ __ ] comments you guys are
making in the stream right now
yeah your weirdos yo weirdos
all right let's go up let's go up let's
fix it john yeah
okay we had real rejects versus double
toast from a nissan the next one
is wolf pack gaming wants to see dashi
games versus dr
disrespect dude dr disrespect got
disrespected but
now he's actually i heard he spoke out
recently and i haven't heard that
do you know what dr disrespect is yeah
tyler hake showed us doctor disrespect
in fact
he's an amazing human being seems like
especially with the predicament every
piece of news i catch a doctor
disrespecting as a controversy so
as amused as i was i'm always like what
is this what what is this guy's the
[ __ ] doctor disrespect man who's
doctor but i think doc what was the
whole controversy with dr district
wasn't he like like kicked off a twitch
he was kicked off
of twitch like i couldn't discern why i
can't i cannot stop hearing about people
getting kicked off the twitch i'm like
i'm so scared to go on this platform
i know this [ __ ] kick you off like
enough hate comes your way
like i would love to stream a video game
but at the same time yeah like i don't
want to get banned from twitch for no
reason at all
um doshi games i would just i guess
this guy's thumbnails look pretty
amusing he's another gamer
and uh i like just the like comedy
gaming commentaries this is what dashi
does
the gif just because i don't know dashi
dashi is the underdog and so i'm gonna
root for dashi
guys i'd i'd have a whole process to do
in my hair now if you've noticed
every day this week my hair has looked a
little bit different
i really this this morning when i or
afternoon when i came in
you had like a full-on sweater i had a
game of thrones christmas sweater yeah
like tied up put up in my hair yeah
special apparatus
yeah then when i let it fall i have to
do a specific kind of combing
method i'm figuring out so much for my
hair
that's where my troubles are at man
growing up in tarzana
god i gotta find the best way to style
my hair to deal with curly hair
it's [ __ ] rough out here rough out
people don't understand
the curly hair like they can't work
right now man i don't know what to do my
hair
this problem won't leave me alone just
follow me around
cobra cobra and
underrated dawn of the planet's villain
hey
thank you buddy i appreciate you
representing koba in the stream today
yes indeed and we got jack sparrow
versus peter pan which
seems actually kind of like it would i
think they would ultimately wind up
allies by the end but i think that would
be actually jack sparrow would
[ __ ] that pan guy up all right
kill this [ __ ] sparrow would [ __ ] him he
would pull off tinker bell's wings
peter pans of fighting the same goddamn
loser his whole life jack sparrow's been
[ __ ]
fighting all right locker he's fought
the kraken he's been ever
he sorry died and came back to life
all right so jack sparrow would
undoubtedly
destroy peter pan moe's death
you got to take these fights as real as
possible especially when we're doing the
verses
this is serious okay no jokes no jokes
here never lose your nerd is next
that's right tm i put work in my hair
this especially this week i put as much
work into my hair as i do this
channel dude greg is constantly reading
hair care analytics 40 hours a week on
my hair
40 hours a week these curls will be
pristine by comic-con
yeah [ __ ] oh boy never lose
your nerd says game of thrones and lord
of the rings
that's a cinematic crossover that i
think okay how about this let's make it
more fun and more specific
now you see micro i know i've been told
microfiber towel mimi
but i i've been just using like sweaters
and long sleeve shirts in the meantime
all right what characters from lord of
the rings
or a character from lord of the rings
sure like i'm thinking jon snow and
aragorn
right oh yeah it would make sense yeah
yeah it doesn't get better than that we
nailed it
okay i'm sorry anything else would just
be like [ __ ] around
the ice the red
wait no who's the chick who's like hot
when she's naked yeah
yeah and then who gets all trouble
she's raising people for the lord of
light and all that yeah yeah yeah
the red queen or witch or red queen and
galadriel
yeah they would work together that'd be
cool put your clothes back on
you would have a queen and she would
wear clothes all the time
and always stay young i want the ice
king and the witch king
harrison golem
she would be her he would be her grey
worm
new grey worm oh goodness gracious
anissa is back in action
you love the monster she always wants
she wants she just wants more people to
be
watching the monsters the goonies in the
monster squad would be
like you would just get an even bigger
monster squad then you know you would
just yeah
you would just get them with an even
bigger consortium of children
i appreciate you constantly shining it
out john do we have a discord link
because
everyone is saying everyone knows john's
hairstyle will beat my hairstyle
uh i live with this guy all right i can
i can give everyone the discord link
although i guess that means we need to
have a conversation
you know how many [ __ ] 6am reactions
here's here's how my day would go with
6am reactions living with john
so much of the time we want to talk
about the hair thing
i'd wake up let's say it doesn't come
out six
i wake up at like five and then i would
take a shower
i'd do my hair i go to the car do some
vocal warm-ups that way i didn't sound
all
nasally and then um i'd flick on the
lights and get the camera ready and then
once the lights were flicking on
john would have his door peeked open the
lights would go in his room he'd hear
the sound
he'd roll out of bed five minutes later
the trailer come out and everyone's like
i love john's hair
that was living with john all right
get everything set up he didn't hear all
the noise and the lights would shine in
his room and then suddenly
oh donuts we're here if there is ever a
hashtag
i would not read it is living with john
the last hashtag i want to read about
you have to do
[ __ ] just feel like wow you just wake up
and he's fine
that's that's that you know get your
hair this long and you pretty much just
have to make sure that it's not on your
face yeah whatever
john oh snap two seconds in the chat you
mean uh
erica uh rachel like our friend rachel
like like rachel
who uh has been on this channel in the
past who greg and i did
rachel from our childhood rachel yeah
rachel jackson she just got engaged
did she really congratulations yeah [ __ ]
yeah congrats
we'll have to hit her up i hope i can go
to the wedding in japan
is she back john how do people join the
disc you'll send we have to send a
personal message
yeah i mean we should probably i guess
have a talk about this because the
discord
initially had been a you know patreon
perk
um oh oh really hey at the moment
uh because partly it's you know got a
bunch of boards for all the shows that
we cover
i don't know how it really works jaw
will have to next live stream will
properly explain it at the very top
i will i will have it set up properly
for uh uh both patreon and youtube users
to have a whole big youtube community
all right koba's back in here saying
ethan hunt
versus pete maverick mitchell
oh oh this is tom cruise characters i
was like who's pete oh maverick
mitchell god i don't know if i ever
heard his
actual name yeah i don't even remember
it in the movie did they even
credit him with the name other than
maverick
even if it was just ethan hunt the man
up against maverick in a jet i think
ethan would still win
you watch [ __ ] that maverick trailer
like oh that took some inspiration from
mission impossible you know
it's yeah he would destroy him
undoubtedly
undoubtedly yeah eric all he can do is
fly a jet he could like
ethanol could do everything maverick can
do
and more yeah i mean yeah he's he can
probably flying a plane was probably day
one for ethan hawk
ethan hunt uh eric horstmann
the united states versus donald trump
hashtag vote
vote blue look guys i don't want to get
political i'm not going to tell you who
to vote for
but don't vote for trump it's all new
yeah yeah what did all our viewers go
away oh is that our
demographics oh [ __ ]
what have we been tending to how did we
not lose them with our kathleen
kennedy's videos what the [ __ ]
what oh man well that's that's too real
eric horseman that's too real
chill level tv keanu reeves and nicholas
cage crossover
amen i love this because it's not even
about any characters he just wants to
see keanu reeves and nicholas cage
starring the movie together
as they should oh yeah
whoa nicholas cash all right
you got to do um him from uh knock knock
you [ __ ] me i feel like my skulls on
fire i'm good your school was on fire
i love i love referencing knock knock
cause so many people haven't seen that
movie
and it's such a meme worthy movie and
it's not even like a
cult hit no movie that like
no one watches it's a keanu reeves
zombie and that's
that's scene at very least ought to be
and yet we love
we love referencing knock knock
probably the trashiest eli roth movie
arguably
oh chill level two get the most coherent
yeah
i'll give him that anissa's back jon
versus elmo it's going down
[ __ ] a puppet i don't care yo i [ __ ]
that puppet
i'll kill him i [ __ ] that puppet off
after the beatings i've taken and these
hypothetical matchups with everybody up
until this point i'll take the w
that i can and i will trounce elmo
tickle me elmo fight me elmo
and he says thank you for all these
super chats anissa is so sweet of you
hey
our discord has many inside jokes i mean
if you guys don't care we can just open
it up to everybody you know
i didn't realize it was only patreon
exclusive
well i thought i was like i thought
there was like a subside for the patreon
ones
and then there was another one there is
the thing is the patreon one is so much
more populated the youtube one that's
just been out on youtube videos hasn't
really gained this was the
first thing you truly created for the
real rejects
and now i'm confused about what this is
i created two with the mean with the
intent of having
one for general youtube and then one for
you know patreon because there's already
you know these relationships that exist
however i believe what i can
do and i'm gonna research this over the
weekend is um you can set it so that you
know
certain boards and whatnot so if there
are like spoiler boards for shows
i might want to still keep those in the
you know population of people who are
watching along with us who aren't going
to just
drop in at random and maybe spoil
something fair enough but yeah but yeah
i'll
i'll fix it up so that there's a
one-stop shop all right
i've got that in my my list of to do's
all right so who else do we got here we
got coba we're on
veto corleone versus charles foster
kane oh yeah citizen kane oh
yeah oh vita corleone would yeah
[ __ ] him like like kane is a corrupt guy
we should have handled this stream with
all these verses like that from the
beginning
oh let's do it what [ __ ] him up he'd
[ __ ] him
cool he was slappish get out of charles
king
shove his foot so [ __ ] him what's next
let's go what else we got and then he
dropped his dead body in a printing
press and the next day's news is in
blood
said i saw knock knock and 5050 said
justice for knock knock
justice for knock knock knock knock
release the knock knock cut which is the
cut that's out watch it
you know what man anna de armas has
gotten a lot a lot of high profile work
since knocked
uh since knock knock so yeah i'll give
it to her and so has uh lorenzo
all right who we got here eric horseman
leave
greg alone thank you but cancel
john oh well funny enough because the
next comment is from anisa
and she says to leave john alone
i don't agree with that let's face it
eric gave a
higher tip in the contribution area of
our super chats
and he fist bumped so let's face it he
won that one
yeah i can't argue with this in any way
i have no ground to stand on
no no no we're leaving you alone man
john we both leave each other alone
on sunday uncle phil
versus uncle phil from
fresh prince of bel-air versus
um john goodman from roseanne
there you go i think uncle phil's got
this clinched
oh yeah oh yeah
all right peter pacheco's back the
monsters versus the addams family
adam's family were [ __ ] up have you
seen what wednesday and pugsley get into
they would have them decapitated at
minimum
nobody so i was just joking i'm just
joking i'm gonna send you a very long
apology message now i was just
joking yeah yeah see how you like it
uh i think the monsters in the adams
family is another one where they would
ultimately just wind up hanging out at
the end and then they would get together
like once a month
right you said maybe don't make
holocaust jokes
i'm sorry do we make a holocaust joke i
i make them too
many times apparently um
oh was the doctor disrespected in it oh
is that it is that what's going on i'm
not sure i'm not sure either all right
kartik but thank you peter pacheco thank
you buddy
yeah kartik sharma first time here in
the stream today
thank you kartik good to hear from you
yeah bruce wayne's done with fighting
days with ptsd
and tan line around his mouth he lives
now under the name
homer oh my god
i love it that i love it
that is how the simpsons should
end we realized you
find out a homer all this time
it was bruce batman
and that's why barb man exists because
it's in the family exactly
oh my god it's perfect and then we can
get a
bartman movie finally after all this
what is going on somebody in the chat
must be making a holly oh oh is it
because of anne frank versus helen
keller
oh and then people saying that anne
frank would have to win
yeah yeah yeah i guess people
in dire historical situations
marginalized and disabled
are probably not the matchups we want
hey we don't need to cancel danny debs
all right okay
i'm going to show you guys how to forget
it's okay danny it's okay we all go too
far sometimes
i have no idea what that's like i've
never gone too far you have joke and
i've never had
significantly but all of my but all of
my videos are your
jokes that's why john doesn't do solo
videos that often
because you know they all get blocked
for percentage
explicit gory graphic content
i love this joke arctic thank you
sylvester saying star trek teams up with
guardians of the galaxy
i like it hey the the recent version of
star trek would actually
mesh very well very well i'm not on your
bad list needs to stop
oh all right
john i'm going to fix it fix it john fix
it so we can read the last
couple see what i need to do the last
couple super chats
and then we're gonna then we're gonna
just look at the live stream and see
what [ __ ] mayhem is going on in here
so the bottom isn't cropped at all
guys danny made a joke forgive now
forgive forgive now do i have a chip in
my beard i think i do
actually do you is that a chip is that
the chip
john do you see something um there's
maybe turn your
face to face me you know the electric
company
let's jump in there really quick there
we go we got it there was a real chip
you know what and and now uh we're not
upset anymore because the chip was
was verified all right we got anissa
hey patreon members coming towards
discord after party after the live
stream we party it up over there and
have a lot of
laughs what is this after party people
get on like the
i think because discord has video chat
now i think people just get on and hang
out and video each other we do need to
wrap this up shortly but yeah i might
want to just pop my head in
and see what it looks like because yeah
i would do i do gotta
do something um but thank you anis so if
they
everyone who's in our discord i really
appreciate it it's cool that there's
like this
community building is there another chip
terrified you want to find the chip
i got the chip it's okay we got it we
got it it's just they're reacting to
that moment where we got the chip
i got to tell you guys my experience
whenever there's something inside of my
beard when i'm editing
i have a whole thought process that goes
on
i'm editing and i'm like and i see
something in my beard and then i'm like
why didn't john say something and then
my second thought is
it's not john's responsibility to check
if there's something
in my beard
it's the way it goes and some of the
time like every time i edit it
why didn't he say something by it's not
his responsibility just tell me if
there's something in my
head okay now i'm going to be watching
now every time you walk in the room i'm
going to be like
your face last looks let me get a beard
check in here before we turn the camera
on
now john has a chip in his beard where's
the chip coming from
also i saw eric said he wanted to eat
the chip uh kartik is back
is there a spider on my shirt there's a
hair on my shoulder there's a little
girl behind us there's been a lot people
have been pointing at that i i think the
chip is the only real one
all right kartik is back hellboy is
assigned to kill
ghost rider under political agenda
but forms a oh what happened three-man
team
when john constantine brings them
together
we just do that yes for right now that's
as good as it's gonna get
there you go what a weird system yeah i
know i don't know why the spatials won't
let
won't just let you what the [ __ ] is the
weirdest work
i know and i have the crop on this
graphic at the bottom like it
there's no crop on the bottom so okay
you guys thought this is written in a
really tiny language
yeah so tiny
what did kartik say cowboy is assigned
to kill
ghost rider under a political agenda but
forms a three-man team when john
constantine brings them together oh you
guys can't even
see i [ __ ] this up so bad there it is
oh we got all three
it's just so tiny yeah hey well done
perfect nope nope nope perfect there we
go oh we can see everyone's
yeah professional live streaming
well anyway we've read your comments so
many times so yeah
i like that the the comic book hella
verse let's do it
thanks i want it and then we got chase
gardner once again
katniss from hunger games versus hawkeye
i think that would be a i think hawkeye
would destroy her
yeah because i mean he hangs out with
powered people yeah he's able to put up
a pretty good fight when the end of the
world is coming
yeah fair enough but it would be
interesting
it would be very fascinating to watch
them fight would hawkeye win the hunger
games
if he was chosen from his district yes
all right well you heard it here it'd be
it would be like uh
hawkeye he'd be like i'm 58 years old
why am i fighting all these kids why are
you drafting me
and i'm not even qualified for this what
a gift
not even the real draft card gets 50
year olds
all right let's see bye samuel all right
all right
and then what is that what does she say
but it's time to chat
we have the after party it's the 18 plus
chat we have the after party all right
so i feel like
[ __ ] i i think i feel like this live
stream
i feel like they're having the after
party right now while this live stream
is going on i wonder if they're watching
not an after party yeah maybe it's like
a watch party that's
not the way it works yeah well you know
i mean since we can't
live stream for six hours you know you
got to be able to get it somewhere
appreciate all that anissa we'll we'll
stop by and say hi really fast
all right and then the last super the
last one here no yeah that's blob versus
the mist
the blob would win because it's an
actual character the blob would be in
the mist
that would be in the middle and it would
absorb all those creatures
yeah yeah i also saw earlier somebody
suggested the blob versus the thing
which i think would be pretty fun mm-hmm
because but think of this though because
for the blob to win they would have to
come in contact with each other and then
it would be like an assimilation fight
right where like it would almost be like
can the thing
replicate the i the dna of the blob
before the blob just full-on absorbs it
i think that would be
cool cool be fun i'm just making sure
that this is
we are having a watch party while it's
happening that's good this is thanks man
all right guys thank you so much for
everything
no longer accepting any more ones here
but appreciate
everyone who we are the entire time you
have been generous
above and beyond wait so there's like a
double livestream going on what are we
just
i think we're just background noise now
people are having a watch party
yeah damn guys what the [ __ ]
we double live stream aiden ah
we were supposed to wrap this up at 6
30. i thought by today i thought today
would be like all right if i say we're
live streaming
4 30 to 6 30 that would give a pretty
good like
that'll keep us on track
nope half hour over hey but but but
think of this
half hour i'm back considering that a
lot of the time where it's like what's
at least a three hour stream
and then anissa just sent another one in
what'd you say uh
or no i don't know she didn't yeah okay
go on patreon the server link for
discord as in messages all right
i mean we have the link here yeah you
know we can get the
if you want we can just post the link in
this chat and anybody who's chatting in
in this live stream can come in i feel
like they've earned it if you guys feel
comfortable with that let's do it
all right let's do it two seconds yeah
we're gonna log off in just a tiny bit
but guys and then everyone's saying good
night already we haven't even said good
night everyone's like good night wow
you guys are really tired of us already
[ __ ] gifts
gifts okay i did call it that yeah
i did call it discord uh invite people
all right we're gonna have a look what's
your worst nightmare for movies watching
i think it was actually weird this could
sound like a joke but it was actually uh
the grudge everywhere i went i would
just imagine
that that character what's her name
what's her name wait which one the
grudge of the ring the grudge
uh kaiako kayaking is uh
is the ring okay yeah i've just imagined
her uh everywhere i went it went like
that for months
yay chase gardner's still here hey chase
it would be the most fun live stream
if if we just stay on so long that it
got to one person
who is the most we're doing this just
for you man
just for you any more questions i know
we might as well hop on the phone
as long
[Laughter]
it's been 48 hours he's still hungry
we do have to go we do have to go got
some more catch up to you i got some
other editing stuff to wrap up
it's pretty late it's late in the day
and then yeah and then we got zack
snyder tomorrow
yeah all the all the work around that
that video that won't be monetized
that's what we do
that's what we really appreciate when
you guys do contribute in the super
chats and stuff like this we only live
stream once a week
so it does mean a lot when you guys
contribute because you know especially
a lot of videos this week are not
monetized so it really does help out a
lot and helps us to keep going
so thank you so much for your support
yes and then the chats themselves
are just so goddamn goofy did you put it
in here john yeah i did it's right there
all right john put it in there all right
guys
got some more work to wrap up this has
been another killer live stream
i have not sweated my balls off to the
point where my hair has become
undeniably puffy
you're gonna frizz so thank you guys so
much
ultimate crossover event would be all
the reactors meeting in person
to do one giant reaction around a laptop
there we go not a television screen no
it's a laptop yeah
and a small one at that like a small
12-inch with no external speakers
it's just the speaker's built-in at
least a ten-year-old laptop
speaker's got no bass at all max rudley
what's up buddy
oh all right guys we'll see you guys
soon
thank you so much for being here this is
a blast
i genuinely loved this topic
king wellix i didn't read your comment
what are you talking about i'm reading
it right now
which i do you ever seen king willix's
comment coming uh no
what did you say some [ __ ] that was
being hidden can you can you give me
like a little give a proper comment
right now send it right back before we
go
you will close can't afford the one
dislike close us out
take us home take us king alex what's
your car take us
you're losing time it's about to end
you're losing it
live stream's about to end ten you got
ten seconds
nine you got nine seconds
seven by seoul six get your goodbyes and
everyone
five and a half five get your goodbyes
four all right so
sorry king wellix point five
one zero mr vahoo
see you buddy ah king willix hold on to
it bud oh
i said open house party at the real
rejects beers on me
there you go if anybody can find this
place you can do the thing you say an
open house party here
yeah join in so come on bye
see you guys king relics thanks for the
comment have a good night guys be well
and